wealth breakthroughs is an exclusive
video series where millionaires break
their silence on their usually hidden
secrets on how to stack up great wealth
it's like eavesdropping on the private
conversations Rich folks have with each
other behind closed doors but I
partnered with the series Creator Jeff
Hayes to bring that VIP pass to you
right here today in episode one you'll
learn how to fix your mindset about
money why women make excellent investors
the difference between good teachers and
fake teachers and where you should put
your money to maximize your returns your
path to financial Independence Starts
Here
enjoy hi I'm Patrick gentempo and
welcome to wealth breakthroughs a wealth
breakthrough is a Magic Moment it's when
building and controlling wealth suddenly
goes from being hard to being easy after
you have a wealth breakthrough nothing
is ever the same instead of punching a
clock working day and night away from
your family to cash a paycheck wealth
begins to build up around you showing
you how to have your own wealth
breakthrough starting today is exactly
why we sat down with dozens of experts
you're about to meet and posed two
important questions one what was The
Wealth breakthrough in your life that
put you on the path to success and two
what's your best advice to those who
want to break free from a 9-to-5
lifestyle the answers you'll see are the
greatest collection of real wealth
building ideas strategies tips and hacks
ever recorded now some of the folks
you're about to meet are household names
you've known about their success for
years for the first time ever now you
get to see how they built their wealth
and some experts you'll hear from aren't
household names but make no mistake
they're masters of wealth just like the
famous faces you'll see look you're at
the start of an an amazing journey one
that could help you break down every
barrier that's ever stood between you
and the life you really want it doesn't
matter if your passion is
entrepreneurship and business building
real estate or stock market investing
the experts you're about to meet will
show you exactly how to start your own
path to Generations long stream of
wealth freedom and happiness now let's
get to it episode one of wealth
breakthroughs kicks off our mission to
master wealth with Kevin Harrington
Kevin one of the original sharks on the
TV show Shark Tank has taken more than
20 companies from0 in sales to over a
hundred million he started his first
business in college and went from being
broke and choked by debt to running a $5
million operation with 25 employees in
just months Kevin's story is in the
truest sense of the word an inspiration
and a fantastic place to start finding
your own wealth breakthrough ladies and
gentlemen here's episode
[Music]
one well Kevin I've been anticipating
this interview for a while you're
obviously your reputation predes you so
I'm really excited uh thanks for your
time today great to be here thank you so
let's get back to your history you you
you've got your fingers in a lot of pies
you've got a quite a background in the
entrepreneurial world how did this all
get started I was fortunate to uh grow
up in a in an entrepreneurial family and
actually one of six kids I'm number four
so my father was was a bartender and he
saved up enough money to open up his own
bar Harrington's Irish Pub so at 11
years old he's like I know where you're
going to be this afternoon after school
he say where down at the pub okay so my
my dad put me to work early I literally
worked a 40-hour week when I was 11
years old after school and weekends and
so but he would teach me the the the
financial operations um uh the
purchasing and it wasn't just I I was
washing dishes and beer backing and
serving tables and and cleaning tables
and everything that you do in fact I
said how do you become an assistant chef
at the of 11 your father owns the place
the chef doesn't show up and you're
assisting your father cooking the the
food right so uh because that happened
quite a bit in small businesses you know
no one's someone's not going to make it
but to make a long story short my father
came to me as I was getting into college
and my senior year and he said look bad
news that you know you're the fourth
child you know I don't have the money to
put you through college so you're going
to have to to pay your education your
your uh tuition your books your your
living expenses your car your insurance
your everything right you get zero
contribution from your dad and so I said
well I already had a business when I was
in high school that I did during the
summer so because my dad again was
mentoring me to be an entrepreneur which
was pretty cool um and so um but now I
had to be an entrepreneur to year round
I couldn't just have a summer uh uh
business if I had to pay I had expenses
every month so because I had moved out
of the house and now I was living on my
own but um so I started a heating and
air conditioning business and what I was
doing was I I was Data Mining going to
the courthouse and getting leads of new
homeowner transactions and so we I
actually called the people and and I
started the heating and air conditioning
company but I offered them I said I'm a
dead St start start up zero from zero
company in the heating and air
conditioning business but what I had
were thousands of leads of people that
just bought a house was it just your
instinct to go there and find those
leads I mean you'd figure that people
who are in that business would already
have sort of a disposition to say okay
how do I go market my business you you
thought of something that probably other
people didn't think of exactly you know
I just always felt that I was trying to
you know I like how do you start from
scratch without an existing business I
got to get leads it's all about customer
acquisition all my life I've been my
focus has been customer acquisition so
um and and so I got these leads from
people that just bought a new house they
had great credit they put the biggest
amount of money they may ever invest in
something into their home generally and
I would I called and said welcome to the
neighborhood we're going to come out and
do something for you amazing we're going
to clean your furnace and give you a
free safety check no charge and so we
were picking up 20 new accounts a week
but most people would be they well hey
what about you know we would talk to
them about electronic air cleaner a
humidifier air conditioning if they
didn't have it and a more efficient
furnace because in in those days there
was something called a pilot light in
most furnaces that burned 247 365 days a
year we had the rights to sell a spark
ignition furnace and and this so This
saved you 20% of your your heating bill
right off the bat just from putting it
in so we went from zero and this is
1977 when we started this when I started
the company um went from zero to a
million dollars my first year which was
pretty cool because in today's uh
exchange that'd be pretty close to about
a $5 million business a million a year
in the 70s is about a $5 million a year
today so so this is long before the
internet long before
uh you know Amazon or Facebook or any of
that kind of stuff so um it was really
old school marketing and it turned out
to be the courthouse but anyway make a
long story short here I was I had a
Driveway cealing business in high school
a heating and air conditioning business
then in college and all of a sudden I
had 25 employees six trucks going out
every day I quit school I was going to
say did you finish college I had to quit
school so I dropped out to run the
business cuz it I would get to the my
company at 2:00 in the afternoon and
they they open at 7:00 a.m. and all hell
had broken loose in many cases and I
just I just it was costing me too much
money not to be there and plus I had to
hire someone to be there while I wasn't
there so make a long story short yes
that that that was it was a cool
business but it it I didn't want to be
in the heating and air business my whole
life for a couple reasons it was very
labor oriented it was very
geographically limiting to Cincinnati
Ohio where I was born and raised and
where this company was and so it was
never going to be a global business that
was able to to grow organically because
I had to install I needed technicians
and it was a local business so I sold it
to one of my
employees and then I had a pile of
capital as a young kid and didn't
graduate from school but I didn't need
to and and so I started um looking to
buy a business so I was meeting with
these business Brokers and they had you
know some of them hundreds of companies
for sale pizza parlor delicatessens
flower shops restaurants import export
manufacturing companies and I'm sitting
there in front of this broker one day
and he's got Stacks and stacks of
companies for sale and he had the books
and records I'm looking at the books and
records of these companies and I'm
seeing what am I seeing percentages I'm
seeing food cost percentages rent
percentages leases lease agreements I'm
like this is my college right here is to
to look at the p&l statements of 200
companies that are for sale and why are
they for sale and then you know whatever
I said I don't I want to do this and I
and that's what I did I became a
business broker to sell businesses to
get the knowledge of the trends and the
and and what's going on inside all these
companies so uh so that was um uh 1980 I
started uh a business brokerage company
and so so now I'm sitting at the um the
closing table somebody just bought a
flower shop MH who who's going to do
your accounting oh do you recommend
somebody yeah call this guy who's going
to do your legal you may want to be a
corporation who do you recommend call
this lawyer what about insurance what
about so I'm giving them all these names
and now the lawyers got 20 new accounts
the insurance agent wrot 20 new policies
30 whatever the number was and I said
wait a minute I want to bring all of
this in house m and so um I leased a
whole floor of a downtown office
building in Cincinnati Ohio and then I
put the business brokerage in the center
of it and I've rented space around it to
an accountant to a lawyer to an
advertising agency to graphic people all
the support people to be able to provide
services to these small business owners
and I called it the Small Business
Center come to the Small Business Center
we can sell you a business we can help
you build your business we can do your
accounting your books you're legal
you're this you're that and it was a
synergistic business that worked
together and it took off it was amazing
and Entrepreneur magazine heard about it
they did a story on me in the process
and I got 800 phone calls from all over
the world so then entrepreneur said you
know I got kind of friendly with the
guys at entrepreneur and they said you
know we are entrepreneur you're dealing
with all these entrepreneurs why don't
we
license this to other people and almost
like a franchise right so that's what we
did we opened 30 small business centers
across the United States in Partnership
and Entrepreneur magazine and now I this
was my I I call it my pre- Shark days
because I was taking equity in deals and
I was you know helping people out I'd
sell a business to somebody they were
struggling because they didn't know what
to do and I'd come in and help them out
a little bit get them someone to run it
maybe someone bought something for a
wife and now she doesn't want to work um
or she didn't realize it's going to be
an 80 hour week in the mall right you
know so the husband said hey but my wife
would love to buy a business but you
know buying a business and running it is
it's it's two separate things and it can
be very very timec consuming so make a
long story short I was this was you know
back in the early 80s now um kind of
takes me from through High School
College owned a couple businesses sold
it and then started the Small Business
Center we opened 30 of these around the
country so so here we were helping
entrepreneurs become more successful
what's interesting is I'm seeing like a
little bit of a pattern form like uh
Freud once said it seems to be my fate
to discover the obvious it's like okay
you're starting this heating business
heating and air conditioning uh you know
the obvious place to go for leads was
where you went but you know other people
weren't seeing the obviousness
in this Cas now hey there's of people
buying small buses usually local buses
they need all the support so of course
it makes sense build a support center
around them this is you know great
win-win for the people who purchasing
the business probably increases their
probability of success a great deal and
at the same time now you've got a
business in supplying these Services
everybody wins so you seem to have this
pattern of saying H there's a need here
I can observe it it's an opportunity and
then you you take advantage of this so
so where did it go from there so now now
at 14 uh
employees that were I say employees they
were really straight commission sales
people and I don't remember the legal uh
definition of of of what they did but
they they were basically commissioned
folks and so um and I'm I was going to a
lot of trade shows and um because if I'm
selling restaurants I'm going to tune
into that industry flowers shops I got
to tune into that industry I got a home
and garden store for sale um you know
I'm going to the Home and Garden shows
so I I was doing about 25 to 30 trade
shows a year which I think even to this
day I still do about 20 um and so so so
now I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm getting uh
across all these different trade shows
and at the same time the world of
Television was something I started to
tune into because here it was the early
80s and I bought it U I had been
successful so I bought a home and I
remember ordering cable television when
cable TV first came to be in my town
Cincinnati was the early 80s they they
said okay now there's going to be 30
channels in your that you can subscribe
to until then if you remember TV before
cable it was only like four or five
channels ABC CBS NBC pretty much just
got a couple channels all of a sudden I
got 30 channels and so I remember
getting my cable uh installed and I got
24 hours of movies HBO 24 hours of news
CNN 24 hours of of Music MTV I get to
channel 30 and I'm going through each
Channel I'm loving this 24 hours of
sports ESPN right I get to channel 30
and there's nothing there and so it was
just colored bars and so I called the
cable company up and I said hey I don't
know what's happening is I really love
this cable thing but I'm only getting 29
of the 30 channels there's nothing on
channel 30 and they said oh you're
that's Discovery Channel it's only an
18h hour a day channel 18 hours of
programming 6 hours of bars on the
screen and I said well why is that they
said it's a new channel they don't have
a budget to produce 24 hours a day we as
the cable operator are going to deliver
to you what they deliver to us so here I
am um uh thinking what's what what can
go in that six-h hour block and this was
now where the thinking started so I I
said to myself I have to put something
in the six hours that can generate
revenue for me and and for the cable
operator because it's it's got to be a
win-win situation and and business I
learn if it's just for you it's not
going to last very long so um so I had
to think what's going to work for them
and for me so here I was at the
Philadelphia home show home and garden
you know research right and and and I
there was one booth with this one guy
and there was this huge crowd around the
booth and I like when you go to a trade
show and you see a crowd around the
booth what do you usually do you kind of
slow up kind of look see what's going on
right and I I could barely see what was
happening but this guy is sitting there
at a he's got a big table and a knife in
his hand he's cutting through a
Coca-Cola can through a muffler through
a pair of sneakers and he said it's
called the Ginsu knife and so and and
like that this guy is selling thousands
of dollars worth of Ginsu Knives and I'm
watching him and I'm trying to fight
through the crowd to get up to talk to
him when he's done before I got there he
started all over again same pitch and as
he had collected money from the last
round and and but it was the exact same
pitch the same words cut through the
Coca-Cola can through the muffler
through the parir of sneakers and I'm
like wow this guy's been doing this for
a while so finally he got on break I
went up I introduced myself to him and
and and and I said hey I'm an
entrepreneur Kevin Harrington that's
probably the best pitch sales pitch I've
ever seen in my life you know tell me
about you know how you got involved in
all of this and he's like this guy he
said well my name's Arnold Morris he
says but kid he said you think this is
glamorous he said I do this 40 weeks a
year the same pitch I'm here in
Philadelphia for six days I'm leaving
tomorrow I go to the Iowa State Fair
I'll be there eight days I'm away from
my family all the time yes I make good
money cuz I saw him collecting thousands
of dollars he said but it's really
grueling and and you know and he he was
kind of he was in his 70s Arnold okay so
um that's when the light bulb went off
and I said Arnold I said I I I have an
idea I said I don't know if you know
anything about Discovery Channel and
he's like what's Discovery Channel right
I said well it's a channel that's 18
hours a day six hours of nothing I want
to do this let's cut a deal I want to I
want to film your presentation I want to
take it down to Discovery give them a
percentage of sales and I just need to
know you and I can put this deal
together and he said look if this will
get me off the street off off out of
having to come to the the fairs and and
and the home shows um you know I'm all
in so that's what we did we um I we
filmed I had never filmed anything
before I mean I was not a videographer
so um I said to Arnold let's do it we
shook hands signed a deal and um and so
Arnold said look why don't we just do it
right he lived in New Jersey said
there's a grocery store closes at 8:00
pm I know the manager because I need to
be around vegetables and because we're
going to be cutting through a lot of
stuff so we shot it at the King
supermarket in New Jersey right the
infomercial right I worked at a Kings
when I was 17 years old in New Jersey oh
really oh that's that's crazy so
intimately familiar might might have
been the one I even worked at okay
that's where we shot this original show
with Arnold Morris and so we put it up
on Discovery and it just went it just
took off like crazy then and this was
just local Cincinnati so then I said I
got to go to the National Discovery
Channel I went to the National Channel
signed a contract for for a multi-year
contract for all six hours Nationwide so
when I was sitting with them we they I
said I want the whole six-hour block
they said oh you know how much you you
willing to pay for it and I said look I
said you know I'll give you a th000
bucks a day MH and so uh for 6 hours and
we ended up getting it done so at that
deal and um and so I'm like in in in the
very beginning 3:00 a.m. to 5:00 a.m.
wasn't very powerful but as we got to
6:00 a.m. to it was at 3: a to 9A was
the 6 hour block okay as we got to like
6A 7A we 7A am to 9:00 a.m. we had
Saturdays and Sundays this time it we
could do a whole lot of our sales on a
couple of hours in in in the day or the
week but this thing by the third year
that um block of time was generating $28
million in sales wow for for
$365,000 media cost so we were making
money and and and then we we you know we
were doing Arnold then Arnold got smart
he said hey
look you were you at the Philadelphia
home show did you meet any of the other
guys like me that had products cuz he
was just one stand and I said I really
didn't I said what do you what do you
think thinking he said well hey I'd like
to introduce you to all the other
product guys he says
but give me an agreement that you're
going to give me a royalty on anything
you do with Billy ma with John Parkin
with uh Sandy Mason with Wally Nash so
all these all these guys were at the you
know basically dog and pony shows like
you know demonstrating all pitch people
and and and they were great pitch people
right they they spent their entire life
learning how to pitch something and they
were the best at the at that particular
product and so but so basically you took
them out of that circuit put them on TV
exactly great scale and leverage exactly
we started with Arnold and and and and
before we knew it we had
infomercials a lot of it in the kitchen
we were doing knives we were doing
blenders we were doing mixers we Wally
Nash said I've got this hand hammered
Chinese walk that's hand pounded and and
they they make them over in China it's
got It's got the original pounding marks
from it so that it can hold the the the
meats and vegetables up and things as
you're cooking keep them warm and your
hand pounding it and so um that did that
that did uh we did four million walks at
at over $50 a piece wow so $200 million
in Chinese hand Hammer Chinese walks
what do we call it the great walk of
China okay and so um and it's so amazing
because I mean now we did that in 1988
by the way um hundreds of millions of
dollars what are we bringing maybe back
to the marketplace just recently QVC
came to us and said can you bring us
some of those old products you had from
the old days so we're actually now going
to be bringing the hand Hammer Chinese
walk back potentially right so but that
was Arnold's Arnold knew all these
people he was like their friend and
they're like Arnold you don't have to
work anymore he's like I'm getting
millions of dollars in the mail for not
just doing my presentation one time I
mean that that's how an infomercial
works you shoot it once I mean Chuck
Norris did the total gym uh 20 some
years ago it still runs the same one I
mean and and he's made tens of millions
of dollars by the way so you know so let
me ask you this so there's no doubt that
um your timing so I want to get kind of
your philosophy on this no doubt that
you know your timing and being at that
home show seeing this guy having cable
just come in and you kind of put two and
two together and we know a certain
amount of success is just timing but
there's also this element of I think no
matter what was going on in any time
you're going to see opportunity so is
this something that is um like a a
teachable skill or is this something
you're born with some combination of
both how do you see all this so what was
interesting is the once we ended up
opening the then the infomercial
business um we decided that okay we need
to go to a lot of trade shows this is
you know where I found Arnold right and
and so uh we started you know I I I so
we hired a few people and we started
with a small staff and so I'll never
forget the very first trade show we went
was at the Jacob Javit Center in New
York had my new team of you know we so
we're running infomercials and I got my
new team and I take them all up to the
show and I just said okay let's all hit
the show you get you start over there
you start over there I'll start here
let's meet in two hours and so um now me
I'm walking the show and I'm finding
products they're walking the show when
we meet I said what what' you find oh
nothing there's nothing here this is a
waste of time my guys are telling me and
I'm like I found this and I found that
and I'm like well what you know so I
hadn't taught them how to do a trade
show right so I said okay look there's
product here you know you can't just
you're not going to just see it when cuz
sometimes the best products are actually
under you know behind the curtain cuz
they're not necessarily showing you the
hottest latest greatest thing at the
show so what I taught my folks how to do
is walk to the booth don't talk to
somebody that's like a a a local hired
person that knows nothing about the
company get to the CEO of the company if
you can if it's if it's a huge company
you may not but you know if it's a 10ft
x 10ft Booth the owner is probably
standing there right and what you're
going to tell them is you have developed
this new industry you're part of this
new As Seen On TV industry where we take
products we select products we create
this amazing selling message around it
called an infomercial and in the
beginning they weren't even called
infomercials but uh and and we have
success now where we're selling millions
of pieces and what do you have in this
booth that might be applicable for my
business and now I took my team with me
and we got oh wait let me I got
something I've been working on for you
know let me show you we walked out of
that show with several deals so yes
there is a way to hit a trade show it's
not just walking it and thinking that
product's just going to smack you right
although I will say this um at the
Chicago houseware show my father who was
my original Mentor he's like seeing me
do all these things and he's like wow he
says you know I maybe could go to some
of these shows and see if I can find
some stuff well he ran in to a guy that
was slicing something with a product
called The V slicer it and most slicers
had a blade that went across but when
you put a tomato through it it as the
blade went across it kind of slid the
Tomato off to the side A V shaped blade
kept it in the middle and you could work
it much faster it was a german-made
product and so my dad saw met the vs
slicer people and said what do you think
we went from that we went straight from
the Chicago houseware show back to
Philadelphia where I was living at the
time shot the infomercial and that went
on to sell over 10 million V slicers at
35 bucks a piece so that did over $350
million and that was something that my
father brought me and by the way I paid
him royalty checks for bringing me the
deal so um because that was something
that I always protected you bring me a
deal we're going to sign a contract and
give a piece of the action and so we
started making many many millionaires I
mean we weren't just making Arnold a
millionaire but the people that would
introduce us to the next Arnold or the
people that would you know or you know
in the case of Arnold he introduced me
to Billy so he was making money and he
had multiple streams of income Beyond
his own products so this I think
innovated a lot of uh the TV things like
QVC HSN because I know that there's
people there also who bring deals to to
them and get a royalty on it so I guess
you kind of like develop that whole
model uh you know from the early days as
far as how this works cuz if you have
people out there searching and
recruiting again that's leverage because
there's only so many places you can be
to try to find product exactly so now
you've so obviously this whole industry
blew up and still to this day as you
said there's infomercials that run for
decades and they've been running for
decades still produce which is
mindboggling to me CU I don't know
really any other medium that has
products that can make that claim at
least nothing com to mind so it's
amazing that it works on TV this way
yeah I mean it the beauty of what an
infomercial is uh because the it it's
important to understand the spot
business existed before me one minute
spots and they would sell you know like
Ron popel that was the Pocket Fisherman
and 20 bucks for this little fishing
device he had the the um the choatic and
he had Mr microphone these were one
minute spots selling $20 products that
cost $2 to $3 to manufacture okay that's
business existed I came along and said I
got six hours to fill I can't fill six
hours with one minute spots let me just
let's sell $300 products let's sell the
gazelle for $300 or $400 let's sell uh
you know I mean the Chinese walk was $40
but we were selling a hand blender for
$99 and but we had 30 minutes to sell it
so we created
this this this industry we created three
10-minute pods in in a 30-minute show
each pod had a CTA at the end of it a
call to action right so you did a
10-minute it it was actually a little
less than 10 minutes because at the end
a 30 minute infomercial was actually 28
minutes and 30 seconds because we had to
give one and a half minutes back to the
station um so in 2830 we had sort of
three 9 Minute plus p
and and they they were 9 Minutes
including a call to action at the end so
that you could actually come in at any
point during the 30 minute show and some
of what was in the first pod would be
repeated in the second pod with did you
start it yes so you you figured all that
out before you even ran the first
infomercial that you well as we were
doing The infomercials because what
happened was this Arnold he said look I
can give you I have an 18-minute version
m of my Ginsu pitch but I also have an
8-minute version which do you want I
said well we got 30 minutes I said do
you have a 30- minute version he said
man I can't go 30 minutes from this
thing you know so the original show was
actually was only 26 minutes long
because we just you know we we ran the
CT we he went 18 minutes and we ran the
show with three two-minute ctas on the
back of it and we couldn't get it past
26 minutes so it it was what it was but
we've learned more about production oh
let's go shoot some testimonials and
let's fill it with some other stuff
right I mean if they're giving you 28
minutes and 30 seconds you might might
as well use all 2830 of course we owned
the whole 6h hour block so that was a
little different because we could just
program that so what we would do is if
we had a 26 minute long show we just put
some short form commercials on the back
end of it but yes we we learned that
some products I mean when you think
about it you can pretty much understand
certain products pretty quickly you
don't really need 30 minutes to
understand them but I can if if I if I
can create the selling message in less
than 10 minutes let's you know reboot it
three times but you also freshen it with
some you know you don't use the exact
same footage but it's it's a similar
style selling message in the other pods
yeah well the thing that you know again
the consideration or the foresight
saying you people are going to join not
at the minute it starts you know and
that they're coming in at different time
so you have all these considerations for
when a you audience member might start
viewing and what you have to take them
through and how to keep them interested
Etc and and you know I've always found
uh you know that infomercials are
compelling in other words it's like you
know you got to it's like watching a
show except that you're really being
sold something but the story so I have
to imagine also having people who are
used to giving pitches you know over and
over again live that those are the right
people to get on camera and to present
the product yes so um exactly that's why
uh Billy Mays cuz these were people that
honed their pitch at the at the fairs
and the and the home shows and and and
they know how nobody's responds to them
they so as they're delivering the pitch
the first time people are asking
questions and they're realizing oh I
didn't cover that okay now they
incorporate the answer to that question
into their next pitch and so this is how
on the shopping channels people like
Tony Little we would put him on M maybe
didn't work the first time well that's
okay because they're going to give us
four airings on a on a product for Tony
the very first time it may not do so
well but you know we have we have
various case studies of products that
actually had a
10x sales increase by the time we did
the fourth appearance so speak to that
for a second because this is I think a
critical um lesson in marketing yes
right same product CU a lot of times you
know many business entrepreneurs uh or
one version of them are product
developers right yeah they've got an
idea usually a passion around the idea
it's like i' I've got a breakthrough
Innovation for exercise like you're
talking Tony Little right yeah so you
got the same product yeah the same
person pitching the the product but you
need a certain amount of feedback so
it's not just the product it's not just
the pitch person but the feedback saying
okay this was Miss missing this was
missing we add this and have a 10x in
it's not like oh we incrementally went
from 10 you know 10 or 15% more right a
tenfold increase Sal so so speak to the
importance of getting the the the copy
or the communication down from a
marketing perspective yes so so I'll
give you a good case study with Tony
Little when when Tony Little first came
to me with the gazelle it was The
Walking on Air gazelle right in fact you
see it in today's national car rental
commercials I don't know if you've seen
that seen Tony's going across the stage
that's our product for you know for 15
years and so um when I first met Tony I
said wow this is very expensive though
it's you this is going to be $400 to
$500 so we said okay well let's let's
put it on HSN Let's test it so the very
first time Tony goes on himself with the
host and and is selling a a $500 gazelle
it bombed and we're like wow you know
this was not so good but they gave us
four airings right so here we are Tony
just went on live he got his 10 or 20
minutes and it didn't do well so now we
come back now let's watch this okay but
Tony you're a fitness guy you you're in
great shape you're selling $500 product
that you use but we're talking to Middle
America here and people that that want
to lose weight yes but you're not
connecting with them so what do we need
to do oh let's get some people on set
using the product also young old open it
up so that they we can now see this
isn't just forbit gurus like Tony
anybody can jump on this so as we
progressed from the first to the second
to the third to the fourth
aing the the we we added little things
each time and the sales were like
doubling okay so we put more people on
and we put seniors on we put women on we
put young people on on then we added
music for fun so now they were doing
this having fun with all different age
groups on set and it just blew it blew
huge numbers by the fourth time that was
the 10x so now we had a winner that we
can now so and and so HSN was ordering
big quantities from there then we said
let's go do the infomercial so we use
the shopping channels to actually figure
out our our pick
hone the pitch and only work on the ones
that that really work successfully on a
shopping channel that was our model in
the very beginning is taking products
that are already tested somewhere they
tested at a trade show they tested on a
catalog they tested on a shopping
channel where did they already test
successfully so that we know there's
proof of concept yeah that it's
interesting I I don't remember his name
up the top of my head but for one of my
masterminds I I invited a guy to come
speak who wrote a book Life's a pitch
okay and uh and really and this is the
thing to understand is that so often I
think entrepreneur entrepreneurial
failure will come from people who just
they have the personal passion for the
product yes there is a need and demand
but they don't know how to refine a
pitch and what you just walked through
because see you say it so naturally you
almost make it seem easy but I I happen
to know this isn't easy it it it really
isn't as far as saying hm uh what do we
need oh let's let's get them to
visualize you know different people with
there you said females older younger
overweight what have you right but then
you also had a second thing and this is
a big deal saying hm let's add music and
make it fun yes so people can say I can
do this and it would be fun now makes
sense it's the same product the same
pinch man these things and like you said
it's a difference between failure like
you said you use the word bombed right
right and and then a 10x yeah sales you
know so it's absolutely and we also on
the shopping channels we'd start getting
Callins and as people were asking their
questions now we're formulating the
answers but we're now incorporating the
answers to those questions into the into
the next pitch so we we would really use
the shopping channels as um as a as a
approving grounds a testing grounds and
a uh we we could do price testing we
could do you know um um
well the the the real Advantage you had
of the shopping channel is that we would
get a call in and somebody would say oh
someone that bought it so now next time
Tony's on if you bought a gazelle call
the line and tell us what you've
experienced and now when you get the
Callins coming in you'd see oh the spike
and phone calls so what we would track
is this where did we get the spikes in
phone calls through this 20 minute
presentation a minute 3 minutes and 11
seconds in we got a a bunch of phone
calls what what did Tony say at that
particular moment we'd go back and track
the performance of the calls coming in
against the you know the creative and
see how do we create this amazing pitch
so we used the shopping channels to
price test to creatively uh test the the
approach for the pitch so how important
to product success are testimonials they
something that are not paid attention
enough to for most business owners or
you how do you see it I I think there's
certain kinds of products where
testimonials are key um beauty products
weight loss products um sort of um where
there's if if there's a magical
transformation
capability testimonials are great
because you know think of proactive
skincare product that you know it's an
acne product you know you can show
somebody with with severe acne and now 6
weeks later clear skin mhm that is the
that's what makes that product work on
TV it's the magical transformation of
that testimonial so um so this is why
with Tony Little for example we said
okay the fact that you use it is great
but we need to get the mass Market using
this having fun with it and talking
about it right so so that's where
testimonials became also kind of
critical but then we could fast forward
and get weight loss testimonials from
people that had used it and lost weight
and got in shape so um I I think in the
in in the infomercial World testimonials
are important um in today's world of
digital where where things are a little
shorter now um having testimonials is
still important but it you also don't
have as much time so you don't get 30
minutes on Facebook
to necessarily talk about a product you
might get you know 60 seconds so I think
the fact that you you know you can have
testimonials is is is a positive
obviously and um also celebrity
testimonials can be even better because
that and you know I say there's there's
a bunch of different kinds of
testimonials there's user testimonials
there's professional testimonials which
would be maybe a doctor or a lawyer
there's celebrity testimonials then
editorial testimonial is a newspaper a
magazine or a trade Journal writing
about your your product which is always
good because what does the industry
think about you right and you had that
in the beginning with Entrepreneur
magazine way back when right exactly
right so here we were with Arnold Morris
and Billy Mays and all these amazing
Kitchen products so home World magazine
was the publication that wrote about
that industry the CEO of hom World
magazine also the editor started doing
stories about our products and and and
these were very positive stories because
he's he's wants to talk positively about
his industry of Home Furnishings right
and so um one of um I'll never forget an
amazing uh marketing campaign that we
created when we had launched a a a
product called the jet stream oven and
this was a a convection oven on stair
oids it went four times the speed of a
convection oven but it was infrared
technology so it could it could
literally cook things almost as fast as
a microwave um but it would Brown and
crisp uh the products instead of wilting
them like a microwave would right I mean
you couldn't take a u you can't take a
piece of chicken out of the refrigerator
put it in a microwave for for two
minutes and expect that it's going to be
cooked properly it's going to be soggy
and and nasty you're a great pitch man
yourself you're making me these products
as you describe them good so so the jet
stream oven we launched in 1991 at the
Chicago houseware show now I said I've
got a 100,000 people that have come from
literally 100 countries from around the
world and what are they there for this
is the trade they're there for the
newest latest hottest products so all
these people are staying in Chicago they
all have to do one thing check into a
hotel I found that Spectre vision
was the company that provided all of the
television to 90 plus% of the hotels in
Chicago so I went to Spectra vision and
cut a deal to buy one channel that in
all of the hotels and that channel what
we did was we put the flavor the the the
Jetstream oven on 24 hours a day and we
and we had a we interviewed the CEO of
Home World magazine and and he said this
is going to be one of the top top
products at the show and you can see it
at booth number XXX and so when you
checked into your hotel room and you
turned your TV on the jet stream of an
infomercial Auto played wow and and then
as people were watching it then it told
you what Booth to go to and so everybody
at the show was like I don't know I'm
seeing that jet stream everywhere well
it's because it was in their hotel room
and they couldn't turn their TV on
without seeing it but it this thing
kicked off in an amazing I got to the
show the next day there was 250 people
in line to get into the booth of the jet
stream oven and we went from zero to
$100 million within 12 months and ended
up that that product became a huge Grand
Slam so that's like again pure genius I
mean again I'm seeing this pattern uh
you know going to see who the new home
buyers were way back when in your
college business saying okay where are
they going to be well they're all got to
be in a hotel seems obvious but nobody
know who's thinking this thing I'm going
to go I'm going to get the channel it's
going to default to the channel when
they turn on the TV and and that's how
you go from maybe a great product that
some people know about to $100 million
you know in sales in the business for
3,000 a day the Spectre vision for three
days for
$9,000 I had a 24-hour channel that
broadcast every attendee of that show
and it became the hit of of the talk of
the show and and it was amazing what's
interesting to me is I speak at a lot of
conventions and I go in and turn on the
TV and there's usually something like
this that's going to be featured at the
at the convention that that I'm going to
be presenting at yes I had no idea that
this is something that you brought to
the world one of my competitors and this
is a crazy story but one day um Tony
Little were very successful with Tony
and one of my guys Tony came in to pick
up a check or something and um and and
one of my guys said Tony he like he had
been in a car accident and he had gained
40 lbs looked bad he was lethargic and
my buddy said don't where's your beach
body and um Tony's like what do you mean
he's like I had an accident I'm not
feeling good you know he's like and then
the guy's like Beachbody Beach he says
we should do an infomercial called
Beachbody this is Carl dler Carl worked
for me and Carl went off and started a
company called Beach poty and they own
P90x and the Brazilian buttlift and they
now have picked up all these Hotel
Channel deal so you'll see Carl's
company is now T they signed some kind
of a deal with many of the hotels so um
he saw the success we had and continued
to uh to Market uh to the hotel Channel
population because they they I think
they called it the traveler Shopping
Channel or something but that's
Beachbody wow I feel like I could talk
about this all day so you are doing a
bunch of Ventures that aren't
necessarily like uh TV or infomercial
based also so what other businesses did
you get into and how did you get into
those so what what happened is um as a
as an entrepreneur I'm off building
these different businesses and we had
more than 20 products uh that that
exceeded aund million in in sales
individually so um that was pretty cool
I mean you know some did a billion some
did 500 million some did 250 million um
we were doing a lot of we did Kitchen
products we did Hardware products we
were doing beauty products we were doing
you know Fitness and and um golf uh the
very first golf infomercial was the
Medicus Golf Club I don't know if you've
ever seen that but it flops and you
can't complete your swing Davis Love so
again I used to go to 20 30 trade shows
a year I love the Golf Show because I
love to play little golf so I'm like
let's go check out the Golf Show Davis
Love Is there and he's swinging his club
and it's it's flopping and he's like oh
if you don't have a good swing it it it
flops in the middle of your swing
because you're not grooving it properly
you're yanking it up too fast if you
groove it properly you can complete the
swing and finish your shot anyway so we
were doing infomercials in pretty much
every category toys golf fishing the
very first fishing infomercial we did
was called The Flying lure so so so now
what happened is um we we we said we
need to raise some Capital uh because
when when you're doing in in the old
days and this is something a lot of
people say how did you do this we didn't
have the money in the beginning so we
would run the shows and we would say
we're going to ship this to you in 6 to8
weeks I don't know if you remember
seeing on TV six to8 week delivery right
now can you imagine ordering from Amazon
today and Amazon telling you oh it we'll
get it to you in 8 weeks right you're
not in business if you're shipping in
eight weeks but we had to do it because
we had to get the order and then go buy
the go make the product I mean literally
um and so we needed capital and and a
public company came along and they said
hey um we've got a little pubco we got
lines of credit if if if we if we
acquire your entity you know you can run
the company but we'll give you the lines
of credit you get a bunch of stock and
now you have Capital so now I started
getting into some financial markets
because and this is now the early '90s
was my first experience with running a
public company turned out out to
actually be we ended up on the New York
Stock Exchange was pretty cool so I had
in in
1991 I started doing public company
kinds of things and and and at that
particular time I I was on the board I
was a second largest shareholder of the
company we took a company from a dollar
a share to over $20 a share we had 25
million shares so at one time it was
worth you know 20 million now it's worth
500 million and that was just over a
couple of years and by the way this what
I saw as a as an investor owning the
stock that you
know if if I had been running the
company personally I'm plugging lots of
money into it and I'm not necessarily
making tens of millions of dollars you
know in my pocket because I'm I'm having
to invest and maybe somewhere down the
line sell the company to get my money
whereas in a pub Co situation I own the
stock I mean the stock I'd I'd come in
in the morning one day the stock is $5
the end of the day it's $8 well I got
millions of shares I just made6 eight1
million in one day it's like you know I
found myself now saying okay do I want
to sell $29 gadgets or do I want to be
involved with public companies that can
create tens of millions of dollars in
value in a day well and that's one of
the things I think that a lot of people
don't appreciate about uh owning a
private company is exactly what you said
it's h you know there's a certain amount
maybe of profit that you're showing you
know on your pnls but you know you've
got to fund the company continue to
funding the operator continue to fund
the expansion of the company Etc so your
real payoff is one day if the company
exits if you sell it exactly whereas
you're saying the public company now
you've got if you have credit Vehicles
available you got stock it's liquid you
can you know you can yeah want to buy a
new house maybe at Le sell some of my
stock it gives you a lot more
flexibility um and leverage I guess inly
growing yeah because it it's like the
other thing because we ended up getting
some lines of credit and things like
like I mentioned but the banks they you
also have to keep certain ratios you
also um you can't be just Distributing
to yourself the oh let's take two
million and put it in my pocket today
fiduciary responsibility shareholders so
yeah so you you know oh I want to go do
this I want to go do that right well you
know the reality is is that you know it
as a private if if you're a public
company you really have you got to be
careful what you do but as a private
company if you're dealing with banks
they they're going to restrict you from
doing a lot of stuff that you might want
to do meaning taking cash out of the
company right so um you know I think at
the end of the day you always kind of
have somebody that you got to be keeping
your eye on if if it's a private company
and you got all the capital in the world
and there's no banks involved you do
whatever you want but many times you got
some Finance institutions helping you
with lines of credit different things um
you know CU we're we're selling to QVC
we're selling to Walmart we're selling
to Target how do you finance all of that
well you can get a purchase order and
it's it's a bankable instrument in in
many cases so um but they're not going
to loan you the money if you're grabbing
millions of dollars out the back door
right so but but public companies were
this is what I started seeing as a very
uh significant opportunity and this was
started in the early 990s and that's a
difference between uh for lack of a
better term a lifestyle business versus
a real business you know a lifestyle
business cash flows really well you live
a good lifestyle pulling the cash out
all the time a real business is where
you're putting the value back into the
business and growing it that way and
your payout comes it's delayed
gratification the big payouts will come
later when you sell Oro public yeah I
mean I had I had tens of millions of
dollars in liquid stock um that I was
allowed to sell as long as we weren't in
any kind of a quiet period but um I
would never have accumulated that
running a private company and in terms
of taking distributions type of thing
right so um so public was something that
really was very attractive to me because
um well raising Capital with a public
company you just you issue stock okay so
it's it's you know it's like um being
able to you know almost print your own
money if you can issue stock to enough
people to get enough cas Capital to you
know behind the public company so we
talked earlier because of of my
background you know you you were
involved in a chiropractic franchising
business was very exciting uh I guess
you have some uh other businesses that
are non related to you know infomercials
and TV sales uh but you're also now you
know you've got this accumulated wisdom
you know that you that you've for
decades of experience um and you're
putting out a a newsletter yes so tell
me about that so um yeah so what
happened is companies would start coming
to me and say I know you do a lot of
product stuff but I just I need some
great business advice and one of the
things that I that I have not mentioned
yet but in
1987 I was hanging around with some cool
entrepreneurs Michael Dell from Dell
computers Ted leanis who was the number
two guy at AOL and he Ted's a
billionaire Dell was a billionaire uh
but they weren't at that time we were I
was a young entrepreneur they were both
Dell was working out of his his um dorm
room making computers and and and um Ted
was was was just doing software but we
said hey let's get an organization for
young entrepreneurs and we launched the
young entrepreneurs organization it's
called Yeo right and we said you you
know we each put some money into an
account launched it it was nonprofit and
we said you can't be older than 40
because we were like in our 20s right so
as we got older we're like wait a minute
this young part is kind of playing
against us because we're now getting
close to 40 we're not even going to be a
member so we took off the 40 we said you
can be 50 and let let's take off the Y
and it's now called EO it's the world's
largest entrepreneurial organization
we're in 155 cities and and more than 50
countries yeah and EO is very powerful
um I'm the co-founder with um um with a
number of other folks um and and so we
so so now I was speaking I launched EO
in Shanghai and I launched EO in London
I launched EO uh in um Latin America as
I'm going around the world not
everybody's in the product business but
they're like hey I'm an entrepreneur I
need some help would you be an adviser
to me so I started mentoring and and
really to be honest with you in the
beginning I mentored for free because I
was just helping friends and this was
part of the the whole concept of EO was
join the the club so to speak now you
get a local chapter but there's national
uh organ you know meetings and things
and you're going to get some great
advice from like-minded people and so in
the beginning days it was my wife used
to say why do you do all of this for
free you're helping this guy and you're
helping that guy and you're helping this
guy I said well that's just part of the
camaraderie of what we've created but
maybe someday I'll I'll monetize this
okay so today I just don't have the time
to do it all for free so now people come
to me and they want some help a buddy of
mine called me he worked for me for a
number of years uh back in the um in in
the the mid99s and he said hey I just
got involved with a with a beverage
company and the gentleman's name was
Jerry David and Jerry he said we've got
we we we we have this little Beverage
Company it's a product called Celsius
and the Stock's 10 cents a share it's a
pink sheet we don't really have any
money um would you help us out could you
take a look at what we're doing and so I
I went down they're down in bokeh took a
look and and and he says you know what
why don't you just join our board um
we'll give you some stock we'll do this
we'll do that and and I said okay great
let's do it now this isn't an as scen on
TV product this is a drink that's an
energy drink that's healthy and so I
joined the board and the stock if was 10
cents it had gone to like 20 cents and
but there was no volume pink sheet and
so 22 Cent stock and I said let's go
raise some Capital we we found a we got
a um through one of my connections we we
we met um uh a big investor in uh Hong
Kong Lee King one of the wealthiest guys
in Hong Kong and he he had a a chain of
25,000 stores in Hong Kong and he said
I'll give you $16 million if I get the
exclusive rights to Celsius for my
distribution over here so that was the
first 16 million and we raised another
15 million and we raised another 25
million the company's gone from a couple
million to over $300 million now and so
um and I am participating in in all of
that now as a as a partner and and and
stockholder of the company so so I'm I'm
I'm on about um 15 advisory boards uh
and board of direct official boards and
advisory Boards of different compan
companies one is a um a company that um
replaces Lighting in um it's called
znergy and it's a it's a it's a small
pubco but gaining some big traction and
the stock is uh doubling and tripling of
late and um and that's I love helping
you know companies get into an IPO
situation because if I can get them pre
IPO or just at the beginning of a a
pubco situation
a lot of times we have tremendous growth
opportunities ahead and that's where I
like to get in on the ground floor so
that's what the newsletter is all about
what's it called startup millionaires
okay so what kind of stuff are you going
to be writing about and talking about in
startup millionaires so first of all I
talk about what is it I look for in a in
a business and how do I identify great
opportunities and that at the end of the
day um it the more deal flow you have
that's you got to have good deal flow
because if you only have two things that
you can look at to invest in neither one
of them may really be a good deal if
you've got 500 things to look at how do
you Whittle it down to get the top three
or four out of that 500 because that's
ultimately what we do is we're dealing
with hundreds and thousands of
opportunities that we're whittling down
to 3 four five that we actually invest
in so so that process and how we
identify the initial products and go
down the line that's part of the
learning that we give the people that
subscribe to the newsletter so is a lot
of this uh kind of sharing your own
experience and wisdom through you know
all the how many companies have you been
involved in now uh you know all this
time well i' I've invested in over 500
and I've had um you know probably 150 of
them that have actually made money and
and returned money back to the investors
yeah so looking at how you filter all
those things what you look for ETC
that'd be very valuable and do you also
get into some of the um Trends maybe of
what's going on in business what you're
seeing you know do you spot any of that
stuff because yeah so I talk about what
I look for I talk about Trends and I
actually in the newsletter we actually
share some companies that we are
following and companies that we are
investing in also so um we like to make
um over over the years and and and it's
it's kind of been a weekly i i t
typically invest in up to 50 companies a
year and um and that's we're continuing
down that same path of about one a week
that we actually invest in so I'm happy
to share with my newsletter Community to
those that subscribe to Startup
millionaires the picks that I'm excited
about because and then tell them why and
how I got there so that's part of that
whole process of the newsletter yes I'll
tell you what I like about this that you
that you're getting into this uh at this
stage of you you're kind of like this
now very um I could say sage or matured
person who's had all this experience uh
my experience in sitting and
interviewing you and and other people
for this series is that boy you know
once I I kind of get into the the the
frame of reference the mindset the
understanding you see the knowledge and
wisdom experiences there is how can I
continue to try it's like okay this is
great I got all this download
information I'm I'm like you know I'm
really better because of it yes but uh
but I also know that dripping it over
time you know is what really dials you
in uh and and keeps you consistently on
the right track as compared to saying I
got a I got a good chunk of inspiration
here but you need to continue it and and
because you're writing now I guess
because you're also doing a free
newsletter if I'm not mistaken correct
startup profits daily and this um
newsletter is is very educationally
oriented that gives um Great Value to
the subscribers on um kind of how we
processed deals and um uh the education
of different Industries and uh what we
look for in deals so it's it's not
necessarily picks like the other ones
are but um it's an educational
newsletter well you know I once heard
somebody say you know uh it's great to
be a Seeker but uh eventually you have
to become a finder and and really you
know you've sought out deals you've you
know obviously you've got a pretty
extraordinary entrepreneurial uh life
that you've lived uh but I'm happy to
see that you're turning into a finder
now kind of giving back what you found
so that other people can share in it
what does that feel like for you from a
filment standpoint well it it's I think
I mentioned my wife earlier that like
why do you keep doing this helping all
these people but I I believe it's kind
of been My Philosophy when I started EO
Yeo which became EO it was to give back
to the entrepreneurial community and
also I made mistakes along the way I had
major issues that we ran into we can
talk about some of that if you want to
go go down that path but um I said I
need to share some of these problems
that I've already uncovered um one of
them was with a merchant account
situation that I I I got just devastated
by you know the bank and so I I said I
need to share the problems so that other
people don't have these same problems
but um I also had a mentor in my life
Zig Ziggler if you remember the famous
Zig Zig so zigg lived his life with this
this one quote that I think is has been
sort of my um uh Mantra also and it's
it's said you can get everything in life
you want if you just help enough other
people get what they want and so um I
find myself you know it's funny because
the Celsius opportunity which will make
me millions of dollars was because I
helped somebody Jerry David somewhere
years earlier but I never knew what
would come from that but you know I went
out of my way to help Jerry and then
Jerry said Kevin come I I want to maybe
see if I can help you get involved in
something exciting so I believe that if
you give back to to the entrepreneurial
Community it's it's going to come back
to you and that's how I've lived my life
yeah well I can say that you certainly
have uh given quite a bit here through
your passion this is one of the things
that uh maybe the final question I have
for you uh you seem probably to me I
didn't know you back in college when you
started that business high school but
you seem to have lost zero effort or
energy or enthusiasm for being an
entrepreneur after decades and after
this success so what what drives you
what continues to drive you like this
well I I do have I've got two two kids
and two grandkids now so it's like it's
cool to to see that um um big Christmas
coming up gonna have the whole family
together this year and I I believe that
um when I look at I have an old my
oldest son's 31 and my youngest son just
turned 22 and a couple of grandkids and
I and I see that the that I want to be
able to hand the Baton and just let them
take it and run from here so they're
both in my business and uh my oldest
boy's been with me 10 years now in
business um and so I I I just feel that
giving them um the access to all the
things that are going on is is is is
good and and and I still really love um
finding new opportunities and watching
them grow and so uh over the years I
mentioned 20 products that have gone to
over a 100 million individually um and
and so to this day I still focus on okay
what's my next100 million success and we
have one this year so um it doesn't
happen every single year but in 35 years
it's been pretty close to 25 now so and
and now the year 2019 we have one so um
so this is this is what excites me to be
able to take somebody that's got
something that they have no idea what
they're sitting on and within a short
period of time develop it into a $100
million success so um it there's there's
there's no better feeling in in my world
than to do that so I I still enjoy it
and um and and now I'm you know I give
my kids equity in the deals as we go
along so uh they get to see the stocks
going up value and uh and hey sometimes
they go down in value but but if we're
doing the right things and and we're
bringing our value to the table um some
of them are private but we also you know
do get involved in Pub Coes but you know
startup millionaires for example it's it
a startup can be a private company they
all start private generally and and then
they move along and raise some capital
and get into a you know the first round
and the second round and then maybe they
go public but I believe that the true
money can be made if you know when to
get in at those early stages before the
you know the the fourth and the fifth
financing round and before they go
public because pre-ipo has great
opportunity yeah and and just so
everybody understands uh when you say
pre-ipo so you're looking at companies
that are successful privately they're
poised to get into their IPO but
typically the IPOs are kind of rigged by
the investment banks that take them
public you know their friends you know
they get you know their clients if you
will and Friends uh in the IPO for them
and then we get the scraps after it
launches so are you targeting right
before the IPO that's kind of like what
you're uh what you're looking at well I
I actually Target even before that time
like right before the IPO sometimes it's
too late because actually sometimes
right before the IPO it might even be a
little more expensive because they they
find out in the IPO there got to be a
lower price so um I've I've talked about
stories where I was offered some pre-ipo
stock supposedly at a discount to Market
but it was a discount to the private
Market but once the IPO hit and the IPO
went down because as you mentioned
there's some riggings going on sometimes
in those situations it's you know if I
would have taken the pre-ipo stock right
before the IPO I would have lost half my
money W so so I like to get in you know
much more at the earlier stage when it's
you know when company's just coming out
or in in the round one or round two
series a series B whatever it might be
early on is is my preference I get it so
now basically and you've got a lot of
experience kind of spotting these saying
which ones are working which ones aren't
working so is that uh one of the things
that you'll be uh writing about in
startup millionaire saying hey I see a
company you can get in on a round now
it's early enough where uh they're
likely going to head towards an IPO and
you're going to really make it so do you
think that's kind of a sweet spot for
investors right now that's a great place
to go in rather than try to go in and
buy stocks in the public market find
these a little bit earlier stage and
pick them and go it's absolutely one of
my sweet spots um in in many of the more
of the companies that I've been involved
with have been um non iOS pre-ipo
startup rounds and and and I mean just
recently we we we made an investment in
in a in a company over in India on a
private Market it was a million doll
valuation it's approaching a $50 million
valuation now and it still has not gone
IPO so um and it's going to go beyond
that so so these are the kind of things
I like to get in on um is when they're a
million dollar knowing that it's
probably going to be hopefully a couple
hundred million dollars soon well I'll
be reading that
newsletter stay tuned I I know about
these that's terrific listen you had
such great energy and information I I
can't thank you you enough for taking
the time to sit and share all that with
us and I'm looking forward to see the
stuff you write about thanks for having
me today Patrick great to be here yeah
so great to be with you thank
[Music]
you hi welcome back one of the things I
love most about Kevin Harrington's story
isn't it that he's taken so many
companies from zero to 100 million over
and over over again is that he's done it
in all kinds of niches and industries
year after year he's a walking
Encyclopedia of practical how-to genius
when it comes to locking down your own
wealth breakthroughs there's a wealth
breakthrough out there waiting for
everyone and Kevin's living proof you
can do it over and over again now let's
switch gears if you know anything I mean
anything about real estate investing you
know the name Kim kosaki from struggling
to make ends meet to a real estate
portfolio of over 6500 properties Kims
the definition of bootstrap success now
here's the best part to achieve that
success in many cases Kim used none of
her own money seems impossible it's not
here's my colleague Jeff Hayes's
interview with Kim
kosaki cim thank you so much for being
here oh it's my pleasure thank you so
tell me a little bit about who you are
and U what you do so my name is Kim
kosaki I was raised in New Jersey just
outside New York City uh when I was 14
my family moved to Oregon which was a
big change and then we took a family
vacation to Hawaii and when I was 17 and
I thought that the luckiest people in
the whole world lived in Hawaii and
that's where I was moving so went to
college two out of my four years in in
Hawaii graduated from the University of
Hawaii and and started in advertising
and advertising sales and my very first
job out of college I was fired and I'm
like huh okay but the company hired me
back and 6 months later they fired me
again and at first I thought you know
what is wrong with me am I incompetent
and I'm like I'm not incompetent but
what I realized is I really hated
working for somebody else and I really
was going to excel better in my own
business so um I was searching of what I
was going to do because I had no idea of
how to start a business wasn't around
entrepreneurs growing up my father was a
sales uh
salesman and in
1984 I had my first date with uh Robert
kosaki and on that very first date he
asked me what do you want to do with
your life and I said well seeing as the
way things are going I said I want my
own business
but I don't know where to begin and he
said well I've started many businesses
and all of my friends are
entrepreneurs and I'm like this is where
I need to be right now and 3 months
later I had my very first
business and uh created a logo
embroidered it on shirts and jackets and
I have a saying that every business must
have a purpose and the purpose of this
business was to fund and pay for my
travel Hotel
and entry fees into business conferences
all around the US and I'd set up my
little stand and I have my shirts and my
sweaters and my jackets with my logo um
and I sold them at all these business
conferences so that I could spend a year
learning how to run and grow a business
um that's how I started as an
entrepreneur so being fired was actually
a blessing in disguise was the best
thing that could have happened for me so
I love this you self-funded your
education I did and cuz I went to
college with a business degree but
learned almost nothing about how to be
an entrepreneur um this need still
exists and it where we continue to put
people through school through college
and somehow think that starting being an
entrepreneur somehow we're supposed to
know that from birth yes yes and they
they keep trying to teach it in school
but it can't be taught unless somebody
has actually been an entrepreneur
because you never know what you're going
to face every single day I think the
keys to really being a successful
entrepreneur one is by far perseverance
and resiliency how well are you going to
come back from a setback I think that's
the probably the number one character
trait of an entrepreneurs resiliency
because every day we're facing something
we don't know we're facing a problem and
if we back down from the problem our
business doesn't grow we've got to push
through and solve the problem and of
often times it's an
unknown my mentor used to say the the
the key to your success is how much
discouragement can you take before you
quit yes yes it's I wish it was
something else but but that's the
reality so right so let's go back you've
started this and to that point though
that's why when you start a business
there's got to be a strong reason why
you're doing it um that's why I say when
it has to solve a problem um because if
there's not a strong reason why it's got
to bigger than just making money because
if it's just to make money exactly as
you say as you come up against those
problems you're going to quit but if
there's a bigger reason in your core in
your soul for why you're taking on this
challenge when those tough times come
you'll keep going so let's go back
you're now you're you're uh you're in
your first business it's a it's a year
youve spent a year learning and what
happens next well then I decided okay so
I've I've completed the purpose of that
business
and so then Robert and I talked about
going into business together um so we
moved
from Hawaii we were living in Hawaii we
moved to
California and we started a business
teaching
entrepreneurship and we grew that
business from two two offices to we had
11 offices in seven
countries and we took that business as
far it was it was a great business we
were in Australia and New Zealand and uh
Hong Kong Canada us and it was a great
business but the model was very
um very labor intensive and very
expensive and so to take it to the next
level we either had to redesign the
entire company or let it go and start
something new so we decided at that
point we had taken the company as far as
we wanted to take it um and one other
thing happened I'll tell you in a minute
U but we took it as far far as we wanted
to take it so we said it's time that we
we end and let's go do something else
now adversity so one of the things that
happened is in this business um we were
teaching entrepreneurial
seminars
and people would come to these seminars
and actually many of them would make
great changes in their life very
positive changes well at the same time
there was a oh there was the um David
Kesh um Waco Waco that whole thing was
happening and there was a minister who
had written a book about
cults and so the the Australian version
of 60 Minutes came to film us and said
hey we want to do this great story on
you you're you're making great
entrepreneurs you're having all this
success and we're like yeah come on in
we're an open book we'd love to have the
story done so they film us and they do
all these interviews and in 60 minutes
of Australia airs and and here's one of
our instructors and he's on stage and it
says cult
leader and so long story short it was we
were not a cult um but it was the power
of the press at that time and so what
happened was um it was called the ABC
the Australia broadcast Corporation um
they had the largest un solicited letter
writing campaign from all of our
students who said you're wrong this a
mistake and they were sure we were going
to sue them and we're like you know what
this may be a sign this might just be a
sign that it's time to move on and do
something else do closing yeah so we'd
close the doors so sometimes adversity
can be the best
thing
so we now let's go back so now you guys
you're you're in California you've U 11
offices decided okay we're g to move on
we're g move on what's the next move so
we started the business in California
and then in 1988 we moved to
Oregon um so the business was going in
Oregon and it was
1994 when we decided to end it and by
that time also we were also investing in
real estate rental properties so we
started that business in
1985 in California in 1988 we moved the
business to Oregon and so we're
operating it out of Oregon um 18 1989
started investing in real estate and
rental properties so by the time we
decided to end the company in
1994 we were actually financially free
and we had um basically when we say
financially free people think we have
you know millions of dollars saved up
and and we can live for the rest of our
lives on the money we have and that was
not the case U the case was that we had
$10,000 a month coming in every month
from our rental properties but we only
had $3,000 a month going out in living
expenses so we had more coming in in
passive income than was going out every
month and so at that point we were
financially free and the beauty of that
is that for the first time I was able to
ask myself what is it I really want to
do with my life now I can take a little
bit of a break take a little bit of a
breather and have the love luy to ask
myself that question and so Robert and I
just we spent probably six to n months
trying to figure out what is it we want
to do and do we want to do something
together do we want to do something
separate and in the meantime we had
people constantly asking us how did you
get financially free how'd you do it
how'd you do it so we're like instead of
us traveling all over the world and
telling people what we did we love games
so why not what if we could create a
game a board game that would teach
people exactly what we did to get out of
the Rat Race and become financially free
so we started working on that and again
we've never made a game it was just we
were just making it up as we go and
trying to take a financial statement an
income statement and a balance sheet and
turn it into the scorecard of the game
took was it was like brain cells were
dying every day
sometimes we'd say I think it's time for
a two- pitcher night and a two- pitcher
night was after working on the game all
day long we'd go down to our local pizza
parar get a pizza and two pictures of
beer and we'd celebrate that day and
then we go back to work the next day and
we finally created this game we actually
had a a gentleman that was working with
us um very computer savvy and so he
would take all the numbers because we
had different deals we had you
know rent real estate deals we had stock
deals we had business deals and we had
the numbers and the return on investment
and the cash flow and so he took all
these numbers paychecks downsized
children and he ran them through a
computer simulation 150,000 times to
make sure that our numbers were were
geared up correctly um and so that game
was called Cash Flow and we launched
that game in uh
1996 and as we were launching the game
we're like we really need a brochure for
the game so Robert said I I'll I'll work
on it so he started working on this
brochure and kept working on it and kept
working on it and finally the brochure
comes out and the brochure is a book
called Rich Dad Poor Dad wow so we
started with the game and then the book
came um as a result of the game so it's
a amazing to me I I wasn't familiar with
the game until a couple of years ago and
I've mentioned it I bet it's popped up
five or six times in the last year where
somebody told me this is what they did
that like their
fortune and their education for their
kids you know was started with that game
yeah that game is how we was what we did
step by step to become financially free
it's it's a amazing it's like it
deserves uh to live forever and and
hopefully replace uh Monopoly which was
based on a whole different principles
yes and they call Cash Flow Monopoly on
steroids there we go and then at one
point um The New York Times came years
ago and to do a story on the cash flow
game and the reporter journalist called
us from New York and said do do you know
you have a cash flow Club here in New
York and I'm like no she goes yeah it's
about a thousand people wow I'm like
what and she goes yeah I think you have
cash flow clubs like in other places
around the world and we're like what and
so we started researching it and we
found and a cash flow Club is just it
could be six people and they just get
together or it could be a thousand
people they get together on a regular
basis and they play the game and all of
the sudden when Robert and I heard
there's 3500 that we've that we know of
cash flow clubs it it made our hearts
sing because because the mission
statement that we created the mission of
the rich dead Company from day one was
to elevate the financial well-being of
humanity and the purpose for the game
was that people could teach people and
so when she said that and we started
researching it and we found that all
these clubs have popped up spontaneously
we're like oh my gosh the mission is is
being fulfilled so the cash flow game is
really near and dear to to our heart
well the our tagline for our company my
partner Patrick and I is movies that
make movements and this is you look at
the movement that you guys has created
all right so I wish we could say it was
all
planned you can now the winner gets to
write the history so you can say yeah
that was the whole plan so we go back to
now you you've got this book that was
going to be a brochure Rich Dad Poor Dad
and that had quite a life that that did
um we took it to a few Publishers they
wanted nothing to do with it uh so we
were forced to
self-publish and we self-published and
where it started where it got its first
push is a friend of ours in Austin Texas
had a one of those big car washes those
Supercar washes with the with the
convenience store attached and so we
asked them we said hey can can we put a
couple dozen books in your in your in
your car wash and he goes we don't sell
books and we're like yeah that's right
then there's no competition so we had
originally printed a thousand copies of
Rich Dad Poor Dad so we sent him two two
dozen copies and I called him a a couple
weeks later I said hey any books sell he
goes nope they're all here goes you want
them back I said no I don't want them
back just leave them and then a couple
weeks went by and I called again and I
said are are there any books sold and he
goes they're all gone and I'm like what
do you mean they're all gone he goes
they're gone I said well who who bought
them he goes I don't know who bought
them but they're
gone shortly therea I we get a phone
call and this gentleman says hey my name
is Bill I'm from Dallas Tech
it's a good book you got here and we're
like you have Rich Dad Poor Dad he goes
yep uh really like it how many how many
copies you got we're like we have a
thousand less 12 or a thousand less two
dozen and he goes I got the two dozen he
said I'll take the
rest and I we're like who are you and
he's like I'm with a small company
called Amway so he was a part of Amway
and that's where the the book started a
lot of it came through the network
marketing industry because we talk about
passive income and residual income which
is the very aligned to um the the
philosophy of the network marketing
industry so it started there and then
the book kept growing and we kept
marketing we did a lot of PR it kept
selling next thing you know it's on the
Wall Street Journal bestseller list it's
on Business Week bestseller list and
then it makes the New York Times
bestseller list we were the only
self-published book on the New York
Times bestseller list and then in 2000 a
woman named Oprah
called and there is an Oprah effect and
Robert went on her show the entire show
was about Rich Dad Poor Dad and Oprah is
syndicated to 150 countries so overnight
Rich Dad Poor Dad went to 150 countries
wow yep and it just kept going from
there so it it hits a it hits a cord
with people um and I think there's a
little bit of a a spiritual thread
throughout the book as well it's not
just about making money it's about
really you know having the life you want
let's pick up that spiritual theme um
and in in your personal life what the
one of the things we've been surprised
at a lot of the very successful people
that we've interviewed in these in this
series
they're it's not the greedy
uh you know the way Hollywood a lot of
times portrays people that have motom
they have a um a spiritual basis to
their work yeah I I I think it is um
when we when we talk about the problem
that you know every business must solve
a problem and the problem we saw is that
there's no Financial education in the
school system and Robert's Rich Dad said
money may not be the most important
thing in life but it affects FS
everything that's important it affects
your level of Health Care your level of
Education it affects how you live
daytoday so it may not be the most
important thing but it affects
everything that is important and so the
impetus for us was that because it
wasn't being taught in school we decided
to take on the task of educating people
all over the world about real Financial
education so our reason for doing it our
why for doing it wasn't about the money
we want to make money but the purpose of
doing it was purely Financial education
so it started there and then um we also
follow the principles of Buckminster
Fuller um who was an inventor
philosopher
futurist who he dedicated his life to
the betterment of humanity and so we
follow his
principles and he talks about great
spirit um Robert and I I would say we're
very spiritual not religious but we're
very spiritual ual and basically he
talked about how how can you be of most
contribution how can you do the greatest
good he has a saying that we always we
always followed which is the more people
I serve the more effective I become so
we operate from that point of view and
whenever anything looks negative or
there's something that we weren't
expecting and it it was like looks like
a problem looks like a bad thing we
always know something good will come out
of it so we're always looking for the
lesson the lesson in the mistakes the
lesson in the failures the lessons in
the um negative happenings in life we
always look for the lesson and that
makes us smarter so I think from that
point of view it's kind of the a bit of
a spiritual path there well I I think I
know enough about you to know that that
um and you guys you eat your own cooking
it's like so you know you taught a lot
about real estate taught a lot about
and it's
also you really are really large Real
Estate Investors talk about if you would
you know what what you guys have built
and how you how you built it there's
real teachers and there's fake
teachers so if I ever want to learn
something from somebody I want to learn
from somebody who's doing what it is I
want to do so Academia is full of fake
teachers you know they tell you what to
do they tell you how to do it but
they've never done it themselves or I
know a lot of Consultants they'll tell
you what to do but they've never done it
themselves so what Robert and I teach
are only things that we've done so um my
real estate investing started in
1989 in Portland Oregon and Robert
started to explain to me what his rich
dad taught him about investing in
specifically real estate investing and
he goes okay go go go go go buy
something I'm like what do you mean go
buy something I don't know what you're
talking about so I I stumbled and
bumbled along and um sure enough just a
few blocks from where we lived there was
this little two-bedroom one bath house
and put an offer in offer was accepted
and as soon as that offer got accepted I
was scared to death I'm like oh my God
what if I make a mistake what if I lose
money you know what if the roof leaks
what if the tenant moves out what if I
humiliate myself all all this doubt was
going on and I was really nervous cuz
I've never done this before
and it was $45,000 and I had to come up
with a $5,000 down payment which we did
not have so not only am I afraid of
losing money first we got to find the
money and then what if I lose it so all
these all these doubts were going on in
my mind the voice was just chattering
but finally push came to shove and the
day came to sign the papers so I I
stepped over the line we figured out how
to get the money which was a great thing
because a lot of people say oh I'll
start investing when I have the money
I'll start my own business when when I
have the money you never have the money
cuz there's always an emergency or
something that comes up so the fact that
we didn't have the money for that
property or the next 10 properties was
the best thing because it forced us to
get very very very creative you know it
comes out of Rich Dad Poor dead um he
says don't say I can't afford it ask how
can I afford it don't say I can't do it
ask how can I do it because that opens
up your mind and gets you thinking so we
got very very creative in how to finance
property is when we didn't have the
money so long story short I I signed
those papers we bought that house and
every month I would collect the rent I'd
pay the expenses I'd pay the mortgage
and at the end of the month I'd have a
whopping $25 positive cash flow and
that's how I started that's how I
started and and
then take us through the Saga a little
bit further how you what does that look
like now today well today so the form
formula is the same um it's the same
formula that we use today on a 400 unit
apartment building as that little two
bedroom one bath house so we bought the
next property and the next property then
we bought a a fourplex then a sixplex
then a 12-plex um and kept stepping up
um and today I'd say we have about 6,500
units we have commercial property we
have four golf courses two
Resorts plus other um plus oil and gas
uh silver and gold things like that but
the key is it's not rocket science and
people are very very afraid of the word
debt they think of debt as a four-letter
word but there is such a thing as good
debt you know bad debt is your credit
cards your personal house your car loans
your student debt that's bad debt that
you have to pay for but good debt is
debt that you borrow for example on
rental properties for businesses that
actually makes you money so
sometimes just getting a mind shift
change a paradigm shift around the way
you look at money and the way you define
words such as debt can make a huge
difference when when you have a lot of
debt even good debt what what about in a
downturn where all of a sudden property
values go down oh that's a great
question that's a great question um
because there probably will be a
downturn pretty soon
uh we're expecting it uh a lot of people
will buy high-end properties you know
they'll buy the the luxury units and the
luxury apartments and the luxury
buildings um we don't do that we buy
middle of the road properties because
for exactly that reason when if the
markets turn then the first people that
are going to downsize are the people
from The High luxury units to the Lesser
expensive ones so we're middle of the
road so we might take a little bit of a
hit um in 2008 we took a little bit of a
hit but nothing serious because people
that moved out other people moved in so
it's again a lot of it is just common
sense and getting your ego out of the
way as much as possible which is why
personally I think women make great
investors of all sorts of real estate
and paper assets stock bonds mutual
funds of business um just a an opinion
of mine is that women are a little more
practical they're less emotional when it
comes to money and once they understand
money and how it works and how to grow
it I see women become great great great
investors I think one of the main
problems for women is not only have we
not been taught anything about money but
what we have been taught is to depend
upon somebody else for our financial
well-being be it a husband or family
member or the government that's actually
what we've been taught since we've been
a little girl you know Prince Charming
will come and is he a good provider all
of these things is conditioned into us
to not depend upon ourselves and that's
one of my key missions is to teach women
about money and about investing so that
they can depend upon themselves and not
have to depend upon somebody else
because all too often we women as we get
older find ourselves in a financial
crisis due to divorce death of a spouse
or just really bad money management and
the next thing you know these things
happened she has no idea where the money
is if there is any money and she ends up
broke so I don't want women to become a
statistic I want them to be empowered to
take care of themselves
financially I I know that's important
Dan I love that let let's let's just do
a a um a scenario there so let's take a
a u um 38 or 42y old woman who finds
herself widowed or divorced she's got a
couple of
kids um credit card payments less income
maybe she's been out of the workforce
for a while and she's re-entering it and
she manages to get lucky enough to sit
next to you at a dinner and looks at you
and says Okay I want to win before this
is over what do I do what would you tell
her what what's what's a a strategy for
her to that's a great question um well
the first thing she needs to do is
handle survival so maybe it is to get a
job or to get a part-time job she's got
to handle survival and get that
stable um at the same time the first
thing I would say to do is start
learning the language of money because
the jargon there's so much jargon out
there and all these you know financial
advisors financial planners stock
Brokers real estate brokers they love to
throw throw out all this jargon and I
think it's just a guys to to um confuse
you and keep you um at their Mercy like
oh you need me because you're not going
to understand this if you just
understand the the language of money for
example in Rich Dad Poor Dad asset
versus liability Rich Dad said an asset
is something that puts money in your
pocket whether you work or not and a
liability is something that takes money
out of your pocket right well so this
jewelry in in the in the bankers world
world he he he or she would say oh well
that's an asset well if I sell it it's
an asset but as long as it's just
sitting on my finger it's just stuff
right or your car is an asset well every
month you're paying money out of your
pocket for gas and insurance and maybe a
car loan so it's a liability so one of
the keys is not calling liabilities
assets it gets people very very confused
an asset is something that will make you
money every single month whether you
work or not so understanding the
language is number one then number two I
would say you just got to get some
education take a seminar go online start
learning about there's four asset
classes there's business real estate
paper stocks bonds mutual funds um and
commodities gold silver oil coffee
soybeans and as you're as you're
learning about these different asset
classes you'll find that there's some
there's one of them that speaks to you
more than the other so I've taken stock
option classes and I've done my darnest
to learn it and sit in front of that
screen and make some trades and my mind
just doesn't work that way and I don't
want to sit still all day but when I
found out about real estate and I went
for that first real estate deal in
1989 that that was my game I loved it I
love walking around the property I love
looking at where's the opportunity what
can we do here to make it better how can
we increase the income um how do we get
tenants it's a marketing issue issue
it's a it's a business and I love it so
you've got to figure out which asset
class you want to focus on and then
start really small put a little money
into the game just a little money
because there's going to be a huge
learning curve so one thing I I tell
women is today if you had today it would
cost about $20 us You' go buy a 1 oce
silver coin and by parting with that $20
us all of a sudden you'll get interest
and you've got this coin in your hand
you'll get interested and you'll go
online and you'll see what's the price
of silver doing today is it up is it
down you'll start being attracted to
articles about silver gold precious
metals just because you've put a little
money down so I think that's really
really important you can talk about it
all day long but until you part with
some money until you're really in the
game nothing's going to start for you so
that's how I would that's how I would
start that's what you're saying is so
true I um
interviewed some Bitcoin experts and so
I bought a Bitcoin back when it was you
less than 3,000 yeah I had never checked
the price of Bitcoin ever and and I said
look I'm just buying this for 10 years
it's just a small amount of money I'm
not and now you know twice a month I'm
checking the price of Bitcoin even
though I'm like I'm not going to sell it
I'm not going to do anything but
suddenly where your attention goes that
grows yeah and so I I I love the the
investing in educa even going back to
your first example of where you
self-funded you know your step one was
to self-fund yourself in learning
learning learning but but that is the
key lifelong learning you you never stop
learning because as soon as you stop
learning you're you're going to stop
growing and for example I was with a a
dear friend of mine and we're Partners
in real estate Robert and and Ken and I
and he said I haven't even told you this
yet he goes I have a new real estate
investment I'm like what and he's
investing in Billboards so he bought
Billboards a big billboard on this land
and he put up a billboard but then he
discovered digital Billboards if you do
a digital billboard you can have like
four or five ads at the same time and so
he's always looking for opportunities
and new ways but it's still a real
estate play it's still a real estate
deal but he's always learning new ways
to um to invest his money yeah and and
billboards are a cash flow play it's
just you know there's not a lot of
employees required for for that to yeah
those are always interesting let's look
and if a 58-year-old
dentist who um invested in his practice
and and worked but his income is tied to
his hours him working and now is
approaching retirement age is it is it
too late to start in like in a real
estate if that's no I I no I don't I
don't think it's ever too late to start
um I know of a gentleman he was 64 when
he started and um also professional I I
think one of the mistakes we make is we
um we don't we we spend everything we
make you know the savings rates in
America are dismal people don't save and
I'm not an avid I I I don't Advocate
saving for the long term I advocate
saving for your next investment and so
one of the things that Robert and I did
early on is we called it the the three
piggy banks and what we did is this was
a time when we had very little money we
had more money going out than was coming
in but we made a rule that with every
single dollar that came into our
household we would take 30% off the top
10 before we paid any bills that money
comes in 10 10 10% into a savings
account 10% into a investment account
and 10% into a tithing or charity
account and we did that religiously with
every sing single dollar and it was
amazing how fast it built up and it was
amazing how fast you figured out how to
pay those bills and we did so today we
still follow the same rule the the the
percentages are just higher but when you
get into the Habit it's not how much
it's not necessarily you have to put 10
10 10% it's the habit of putting that
money aside because it will grow really
really quickly and that can be your
first investment funding for you um so
going back to our 64 year old guy um he
started small started investing in real
estate he bought a a duplex and he
bought a fourplex and this was overtime
he had saved up some money and so he
bought that and he was making like
$8,000 a month and that was a great
start for him he that was almost H
100,000 a year without him working and
then what happens is um you can live
quite you know not necessarily frugally
but keep putting some of that cash flow
aside from the properties and that cash
flow then funds your next property and
then funds your next property so it's
not rocket science it's just number one
is kind of developing The Habit getting
some education getting that first deal
done and then learning and learning and
learning and keep
growing to me this this almost goes back
all the way to the beginning to the cash
flow game yeah it is that it it's it's
getting your mind you the just the
basics of this um to build on I I Marvel
at this that you know had I had a long
entrepreneurial career with spectacular
highs and equally
spectacular we all have crashes when you
augur one of these into the ground it is
not pretty and that you know if I had it
all to do over again I would have built
what you guys built where you built
where you made your yourself financially
free and that's the point where you can
decide yes to take these you know
entrepreneurial risks yeah that was that
was the luxury luxury point where we
said what is it we want to do and I love
that you say the cash flow game because
we are very much getting back to the
core mission of why we started the Rich
Dad company and that was the Cash Flow
game and it was people teaching people
so we actually have launched a whole new
initiative where we are putting a lot of
time and attention into these cash flow
clubs supporting the clubs giving more
education um actually letting them turn
it into a business if they want to some
people just want to play the game and
they want to learn and they they teach
each other and they learn from each
other and they invest from there but we
have something that's very unique that
nobody else has which is the cash flow
game so we really want to um applaud the
people that are using it and playing it
and learning from it and actually
teaching other people Financial
education that's the core to us and
that's where we're going to put all of
our time and attention well I love the
movement that you started and what you
guys I don't know really I can't think
of anyone else who's had a more positive
impact on on people's finances than what
you and Robert built yeah and I love
that you did that and love that you're
still in in in enthralled with it today
yeah I am I am I'm working on a new real
estate deal right now of course you are
and we're working on those cash flow
games and Robert's writing more books
and um I think the most important thing
is when we travel all over the world
when somebody comes up and says thank
you for the work you've done that's the
most humbling thing at all of all and we
don't do it for the money we don't do it
for the acknowledgement um we set out to
as as Buckminster Fuller said where can
you be of best contribution he said
don't ask what it is you want to do what
is it God wants you to do and so that's
what we keep following what what are we
here to do where can we make the
greatest contribution and that's what
drives us it's so great Kim thank you so
much thank you
[Music]
Jeff Kim just showed you the blueprint
for True Freedom owning assets that pay
you while you sleep go golfing or hang
out with your family owning income
produc ing real estate is one of the
best ways to go from zero to a wealth
breakthrough in no time flat now let me
ask you a question do you know what the
ultimate wealth breakthrough blueprint
is have you ever heard of it or let me
ask you this one do you know how to
retire rich on just $190 a month for the
answer to both questions let me
introduce you to one of the most
revolutionary thinkers in America today
when it comes to wealth building
strategies I'd like you to meet
Alexander green Jeff talked with
Alexander recently and here's what
happened so Alec thank you for being
here I've been looking forward to this
interview thanks for having me so tell
us a little bit about who you are and
what it is that you do okay U well my
name is Alec green I uh live in
Charlottesville Virginia and Orlando
Florida share homes there and I'm the
chief investment strategist of the oxy
club which is a private club it's
dedicated to showing people how to
achieve and maintain Financial
Independence and eventually I write
about what's happening in the world in
the economy and the markets and make
recommendations that people can act on
to further their their net worth so how
did you get to this there there has to
be a story here there's a long and
Winding Road good let's take it well let
me Begin by saying I've always been
fascinated by money I came from a a a
very middle class household in a small
town Stanton Virginia I often say I grew
up in a Norman Rockwell painting a
little little quiet town in the sheno
valley and uh we had a few people in our
town who were very wealthy and I sort of
looked up to those people every time
they needed to raise money for some
project or some worthy calls whatever
they would go to these people first and
I always thought like wow what what did
these people do they must be a little
smarter a little sharper worked a little
harder and I was fascinated by money how
it's earned how it compounds how it's
created and so forth um but
unfortunately in school they really
don't teach to much about money you know
most high schools in the United States
still don't even teach basic personal
finance it's as if money is something
that either doesn't really matter or
you're just supposed to figure it out on
your own and uh so people graduate from
high school and they don't know what
compound interest is or a 401k or what
an adjustable rate mortgage is or or why
we even have a stock market and then
oftentimes they go off to college and
their professors tell them that we live
in this unfortunate economic system it's
based on Greed and selfishness and
exploitation which is such a
mischaracterization because you know the
beautiful thing about capitalism is it
says you can have anything you want if
you just provide enough other people
what they want I mean what a beautiful
foundation so that's not greed and
selfishness that's how do you get rich
by helping other people get what they
want and the more people you help the
Richer you'll get people like Jeff Bezos
and and Bill Gates have helped millions
and millions of people probably billions
and so they're they're billionaires
themselves so so I've always been
fascinated by money I think a lot of
people are fascinated in how to spend it
but I'm interested in how to grow it and
and uh so I majored in business and
psychology at college and then not long
afterwards I found myself working in the
money management industry and I I became
my passion to show people how to achieve
and maintain Financial Independence and
so I retired from Wall Street actually
almost 20 years ago now and I've devoted
my professional career to showing
Everyday People how to become wealthy
and and I I say how to become wealthy
because there are principles of wealth
creation that are well understood but
just not by most people so I I talk
about those things write about them
regularly and show people the path to
financial Independence okay so you
you're you're in the dead center of the
whole purpose of this series and and and
we talk about this financial illiteracy
and you know I know phds and medical
doctors that still know nothing about
money I had them as clients I you're
exactly right so let's go back you know
starting from that blank canvas these
principles you're talking about what how
can we help somebody to day what they
need to know about creating wealth okay
well the first thing they should know is
everybody should be rich in America when
I say everybody you might SE seen the
story a few years ago of this fellow who
died in Vermont and he had he had two
jobs he was a gas station attendant and
he was a janitor at JC peny and the
community was stunned when he died and
left $8.6 million to the local library
and how had he done that all he had done
is work save invest and compound his
money over a long period of time again
gas station attendant wow and JC
Penney's janitor that those are his two
jobs no great inheritance no great
connections no high-paying job no high
education nothing okay so I always say
if if you're not rich in this country
one of these things is true you either
haven't worked or you worked and you
didn't save or you saved but you didn't
invest or you invested but you didn't do
it properly or you did it properly and
successfully but you couldn't keep your
hands off the money you spend it on the
the new boat the this bigger house
whatever so really there's a fellow by
the name of Dr Thomas Stanley who wrote
a book called The Millionaire Next Door
probably 20 years old now and he
surveyed the nation's most affluent
people to determine how they became
wealthy and I think the conventional
wisdom is if you're if you're rich in
this country you founded a computer
company in your garage or you play third
base for the Yankees or you had a
million selling record whatever that's
not the case I mean those people are
rich and for those reasons but most
people simply worked and saved and
invested and compounded their money over
a long period of time and that's
something it's open to anybody if
they're willing to work save invest in
compound so if somebody is my age 60
years old is it too late to write my
financial ship it's it's never too late
to get started no matter where you are
if if you're later in life you're going
to need to save more you're going to
probably need to earn a higher rate of
return and you may need to work a little
longer in order to let your money
compounds but it's never too late to get
started never there's never a bad time
to make a good investment so let's take
somebody that's a like I'm thinking
about I've got kids that are now in
their 30s yeah what would you map out
for them as a strategy to end up wealthy
well the first thing you should tell
your kids is they have a huge asset that
you don't have lots of time ahead of
them I mean I'm I'm about the same age
as you are so I know that if I was
starting now it' be tough for me for me
to develop the net worth I have now but
they are in a situation where if they
saved just a little bit of money for
instance Let me Give an example if your
kids save $190 a month and they may have
to scrape and cut some Corners to do
that they saved $190 a month and nothing
more and they invested in say the S&P
500 Index Fund which is generated a 10%
average compounded return for over a 100
years and they earned nothing more than
that 10% return from the age of 25 to 65
they would have over a million dollars
if they reinvested their dividends $190
a month every month for 40 years you've
got over a million dollars and yet look
at the United States today 40% of
Americans live paycheck to pay check 40%
say they couldn't get their hands on
$400 in an emergency now if someone
can't work has mental or physical
debilities I I'm fully for a social
safety net for people for the what
Ronald Reagan used to call the truly
needy but that doesn't describe 40% of
Americans what's happening is people are
spending everything they're making uh
they're not saving they're not inv
investing and they're not compounding
their money and if they would get on the
right track starting today then they can
have a financial future that's much more
secure than otherwise and think about it
what is money money is power if you're
doesn't matter whether you're male or
female old or young black or white gay
or straight educated or not if you have
money you have power in the best sense
you have security Peace of Mind choices
about how you can live your life where
you can live what you're going to do who
you're going to do it with you have all
those choices if you don't have money
life is is a is a is a constant strain
you're you're you're you you're worried
about your bills you're worried about
your future you're worried about being
able to help people in need your kids or
the Charities that you want to donate to
so it makes the whole difference and
that's why it's such a shame um that
financial literacy in this country is so
low and it's such a good thing that
you're doing this series to teach people
the basic financial literacy they need
to move forward and enjoy some type of
Financial Security so it's interesting I
know you have have specific strategies
and I know people come to you for
because of your experience but a lot of
what you're talking about is just this
Preparatory mindset it is the delayed
gratification of uh choosing wealth over
a new boat you know what it's almost
like raising a garden it's it's
beautiful to plant the seeds and nurture
the seeds and pull out the weeds and
watch them grow and and at the end you
have this beautiful garden if you if you
can start to enjoy the process and not
just think about what you're sacrificing
now and and you don't this doesn't mean
that you you don't enjoy yourself it's a
matter of finding balance no I'm not
saying to someone should save every
every penny they possibly can but if
they're saving nothing I mean Let me
Give an example if if someone told you
tomorrow that you're going to have to
live on 10% less by hook or by crook you
would find a way to live on 10% less
most people could save at least 10% of
their after tax take-home pay they
should be doing that and if they could
afford to save more they should be doing
that so it's just a a matter of getting
into that mindset and realizing that
that what you're going to realize down
the road is a level of of Independence
and and freedom that other people can
only dream about yeah I had a business
coach several years ago that like a
savings account is not exciting it's
like I remember as a kid uh my parents
make we had an old savings and loan and
you know my parents making me put money
from my paper out in my savings account
and I would much rather convert it into
Snickers and and you know something
useful like that and that boringness and
then this business coach I had talked to
me about setting up a wealth account MH
and you know it's a separate from a
savings account and the wealth was
account was something I was going to
build for me to build wealth and for
some reason that was exciting to me I'm
not just saving money that I don't get
to spend I'm Building Wealth if somebody
is you know is willing to build a wealth
account what advice are you giving
people now of how to build that wealth
inside the money that inside their
wealth account well I would begin by
saying that when you talk about a
savings account there there is a a
truism that if you take very low risk
you're going to earn very low returns
right so you're going to have to get
comfortable with the idea that to earn
higher than average returns you're going
to have to see fluctuations sometimes
pretty wide fluctuations in the value of
your investments from month to month and
even week to week and day to day I I
encourage people not to watch their
Investments too closely it's not
necessary if you're investing to reach a
financial goal 10 or 20 or 30 years down
the road what the stock market does this
week or this month is totally irrelevant
and and and one of the things that's
that's not taught that should be taught
is uh the stock market has given on
average a 10% return for the last 200
years and I encourage people to read an
investment classic by Dr Jeremy seagull
of the Wharton School called stocks for
the long run and he shows that over long
periods of time stocks generate much
higher than returns in any other type of
investment and he he goes all over the
world and one of the most interesting
things in the book I thought was even if
you had invested in the German stock
market and the Japanese stock market on
the eve of World War Two And even though
those countries fa total economic and
political
destruction 30 years later Japanese and
German stocks had returned exactly what
US Stocks had returned it it shows the
incredible resilience so even when we
have wars recessions depressions
Corrections all all kinds of setbacks um
stocks are resilient and the reason for
that is we all have economic needs not
least of which are food clothing shelter
healthare Etc okay it's not the
government that provides these things
it's private businesses and so they have
to find a way to offer these goods and
services and make a profit and over time
as their sales and their profits rise so
does the value of the business and so
all these stocks are doing is reflecting
the rising value in the of the companies
themselves and so if you're a young
person especially and you're looking at
a at investment goals decades away you
should essentially be 100% invested in
stocks and yes you're going to see some
hair raising bumps along the way that's
inevitable but if you can resist the
urge to panic and sell to do something
unless that do something is to add to
your stocks while they're cheap that's
that's the something you should do when
I'm writing my investment letters when
those periods come along like during the
Great Recession I said very clearly
you're looking at one of the great
buying opportunities of your lifetime
and and you can either panic and sell
and regret it or you can add to your
Holdings reduce your average cost and
reap the benefits as the market returns
to normal and that's exactly what's
happened we've had this incredible
almost 11year run we'll have downturns
again in the future and that's fine
because behind every bare Market is
another bull market and so it doesn't
don't worry about the people that tell
you about oh a bare Market's coming yeah
a bare Market is coming and another one
after that another one after that but
the history of the stock market is
higher highs and higher lows so the
first thing I would say is save yes but
invest your money in the best returning
asset of alltime Common Stocks and is
your advice to your readers is it is it
mostly this long-term strategy no it's
partly a long-term strategy I have some
I wrote a book it was a national
bestseller about uh 12 years ago called
the gone fishing portfolio and all the
gone fishing portfolio is is a portfolio
of Vanguard index funds that you invest
in and you rebalance them once a year
takes 20 minutes a year the rest of the
time you're you're encouraged to go
fishing which is why it's called G
fishing portfolio and that's all it
takes is a few minutes to set it up and
20 minutes once a year to rebalance it
and that's a long-term asset allocation
plan and if that's all someone did they
would probably earn a generous return
and $100,000 invested in that portfolio
the Inception is worth almost a half
million dollars now and it's very
conservative portfolio it's 30% bonds
but most people want to be more active
like for instance if you're in your 60s
and you say wow I should have saved more
I should have saved earlier that you
probably want to do something to to earn
even higher rates of return and so for
those people I suggest they own
individual stocks because uh for
instance I've been a shareholder not
just for years but for decades of apple
and Amazon and Netflix and other
companies that have gone up many many
fold right and so you get a performance
Boost from owning companies that
outperform The Benchmark the averages by
a substantial margin so what are
companies right now that are the Amazon
Netflix of the future well we wish we
could know but you knew you knew apple
and but you know what here's the thing I
won't try to brag about any great
perspicacity when I bought those stocks
here's an interesting thing that
happened to me one of the thing is if
you're a learner and you're interested
in how to make your money grow faster
you I found that if I listen to the
smartest people at managing money I
could do better with my own money and so
two of the people I used to listen to
were Warren Buffett who decades ago as
as now was was running Berkshire
Hathaway and Peter Lynch who's retired
now but was the manager of the Fidelity
mellin Fund and he is the best
performing Equity manager of all time so
one month I just happened to be reading
some things that these guys had written
and first of all Peter Lynch said you
know if you patronize a company you
really ought to consider owning its
shares because if you like the company
probably other people like the company
if other people like the company then
probably the sales and earnings are
going to grow and and so you should
consider investing in the companies you
patronize yourself and I thought to
myself hey that makes a lot of sense and
the same month I read something from
Warren Buffett which was which was
equally interesting and he said you know
the capital gains tax is not a tax on
capital gains it's a tax on transactions
and by that he meant if you don't sell a
stock you don't know any capital gain
tax and that's one of the reasons he's
one of the richest men in the world his
fortune is almost entirely untaxed so so
I thought to myself wow if I buy the
companies that I patronize and I don't
sell them then I could have a a huge
gain in no taxes well I was a I was a
Mac guy long back when Windows ruled
Supreme and there was no such thing as
an iPhone or even an iPod this is how
long ago I bought my apple right but I
bought the stock and I held it and
Amazon I mean I was using Amazon as an
internet user from the very beginning so
I bought some Amazon and Netflix I had a
neighbor who came over with that little
red envelope with they used to put the
DVDs in showed me that I said I'm going
to buy some of that this is before they
had streaming or so so I I I I had no
conception that that Apple was going to
become what it did and Amazon was going
to become what it did and Netflix would
become what it did and quite frankly
there are some companies I invested in
that went right down the tubes but a
company can only drop 100% in value it
can go up many 100 100 fold or more
which those stocks are all up over 100
fold so it wasn't some some fantastic
business Insight that I had it was a the
fact that I patronized these companies
and I don't want to pay taxes I owned
them all in a non-retirement account if
I sold them I'd own owed a big capital
gain sex so I just held them and now for
instance the the dividends I get off of
Apple are are many many times the value
of my original investment so so for
example with Amazon the annual dividends
that I receive are many times the the
amount of the total investment I made in
the stock originally so that that's what
happens when you hold on to a great
company for a long period of time and
I'd love to be able to sit here and tell
you what the apple and the Amazon and
the Netflix of are of tomorrow but we'll
never never really know what we're
looking in the rearview mirror right and
that's why you want to own a diversified
portfolio of great companies um and the
truth of the matter is most people would
have a small fortune for themselves if
they'd gone out and bought some shares
of the company that they they have their
cell phone planned through like Verizon
or AT&T or that they bank with like Bank
of America or JP Morgan or car brand
they buy Ford or BMW I mean over year
the years these stocks have gone up and
up and up so so you don't have to be a
macroeconomist you don't have to be a
market timer or a or a fantastic stock
picker that strategy I just I mentioned
is just about buying the companies you
patronize and hanging on to them if if
if you got to the point where you
thought that Ford was making lousy cars
instead of Great Cars you probably want
to sell the stock but if you continue to
be a happy customer and you like the new
models and you like the quality and you
like the price is it would be a good
reason to hang on and I I like this
concept because it offers consistency
with my own values if you know if I see
a company that I think is doing good in
the world I would actually enjoy having
that in my portfolio if I have a company
that I think is is making the world a
worst place I will enjoy not having that
in my portfolio it sounds like you'd be
interested in socially conscious
investing that's become a a big deal and
it's interesting where I believe that
company's just doing well you know
whether they're making a a a social
contribution or making a social
contribution like capitalism you know a
rising tide lifts all boats and so this
was missing for me in the first part of
my financial career is participating
this and I literally had to be shown the
joy of being a part of it but I really
like your philosophy of pick companies
that you like that you patronize yeah I
I like owning Apple because I I spend
enough on Apple that the company can
probably do okay just on me yeah right
yeah yeah believe me my Apple stock has
paid for all the Apple products I've
bought over the years many times over so
what are things that have your interest
right now or that you're recommending uh
to your readers right now well I I use a
number of different strategies and let
me just explain one particular strategy
and and how it works and why um one of
the things I've done very well with over
the years is buying the same stocks that
the Insiders are buying now in today's
world anybody who knows anything about
anything is called a Wall Street Insider
but from a legal standpoint an Insider
is an officer a director which means a
member of the board of directors or a
beneficial owner which means he owns 10%
or more of the outstanding shares of the
company and these people uh have access
to material non-public information about
the future prospects of the business and
so when these people uh go in the market
to buy or sell their own company shares
they have to file what's called a form
four with the SEC detailing how many
shares they bought on what date at what
price and this information becomes
immediately available and so I'm
tracking these SEC filings on a daily
basis and so when I see that the CEO of
a company the president the chief legal
counsel any of the Insiders buying
millions of dollars with their own
company stock with their own money at
the current market prices then we ride
their coattails and uh no investment uh
strategy is foolproof uh but generally
it works off in fact there's been lots
of U academic studies that have shown
that uh that 6 months after an Insider
buys his own company stock the shares
tend to be significantly higher than the
market so what I often do is just
recommend stocks based on heavy Insider
buying by the the officers and directors
that's great because people generally
act in their own and their own
self-interest their own best interest
true there are lots of reasons an
Insider might sell his own company
shares that have nothing to do with the
Outlook of the business he might be
diversifying his portfolio he might be
putting his kids to an expensive private
school maybe he's getting divorced and
he has to sell half his shares who knows
but there's only one reason that the
Insiders would buy huge amounts of their
own company stock with their own money
and that is given all they know about
the company about its customers its
employees its suppliers its competitors
including all sorts of material
non-public information they feel the
stock is trading for a lot less than
what it's worth so it tends to be a very
good good signal if you were just going
to do one thing to enter the market
would that be the strategy if I was
going to buy individual stocks and I
could only follow one strategy that
would be the the one strategy I'd follow
i' I've used other techniques that are
also very effective but I think that the
the value of this is you you know I mean
it it kind of just Rings everybody's
Bell as it of course nobody knows more
about these companies than people
running it and maybe they're not 100%
right but they're going to be right more
than they're wrong and so if I had a
divver verified portfolio of stocks
being accumulated by the Insiders that'd
be a pretty good way to go yeah it's
what strikes me about this is I know
that the person is sincere if he's
betting his own money now he can be
sincerely wrong but at least I'm on the
sincere side right of the equation right
I will if you give an example when it
didn't work out because I want to say
that there's no foolproof investment
technique I mean whether you're looking
at growth value Arbitrage Insider buying
nothing's foolproof John Scully when he
came in from Pepsi and kicked out steeve
jobs at Apple he not only bought
millions of dollars of the stock he
mortgaged his home he bought all the
stock and then he drove the company into
the ground this this was actually right
when I bought Apple was when Steve Jobs
first came back so sometimes the
Insiders are wrong in fact he was the he
was really what was wrong I mean apple
is not the culture of Pepsi and he tried
to turn it into just another Fortune 500
company which is not what Apple a kind
of classic company was not not that kind
of a business um so sometimes the
Insiders are wrong but more often than
not they're right and they know things
that you can't know people often will
ask me like well what what did that
chairman know when he bought those
shares back then they were so low you
can't really know what it is that they
know later on you'll find out that the
earnings come in better than expected or
there's a new product launch but but
that's just it they know all sorts of
things that are going on behind the
scenes that those of us on the outside
looking in couldn't possibly know they
they look they know about the new
products they know if the company's
considering any takeovers or or being S
as a takeover themselves they know
whether any litigations about about to
be settled they know if the company's
gained or lost any major customers they
just know all sorts of things and as
time goes by these things become news
and the News moves the stock higher so
every public company has insiders so
that you know that gives you a pool of
every public company in the world how do
you narrow that focus a little bit in in
your world right yeah it'd be great if
you just saw an Insider buy a few shares
then you buy shares and everybody makes
money but like most things in life it's
not quite that easy do quite a bit of
due diligence and here's what I'm
looking for the first thing I'm looking
at is the size of the transactions I I
don't want to to buy a stock that
someone bought $50,000 of 100 I wanted
to buy millions of dollars or the stock
to because greater volume means more
conviction I'm looking at the track
record of The Insider has he bought the
stock in the past and if he had he
bought it before did he buy it low and
sell it high and often times an officer
at one company will sit on the board of
directors at another company well that's
also public information so I look at
those stocks you bought as a board
member did he buy those shares high and
buy them low and sell them High and the
the better their track record in the
past the higher I score their Insider
buying now um I'm looking for widespread
Insider buying it's great if the CEO is
buying some shares but if the
president's buying shares the chief
legal council's buying chairs the
Chairman's buying chairs that that I'd
like to see some reinforcement um I I
often look for what I call the
Divergence indicator and by that I mean
ordinarily when you see Insider buying
there's been a problem at the company
there's been an earn miss or a product
recall or a class action suit that's
knocked the stock down and the Insiders
will come in and start buying the stock
and what that generally means is yes we
got a problem but it's not the end of
the world and the stocks there been an
overreaction the stock but paradoxically
when the Insiders buy at the high end of
the range it's an even better signal and
you might think that seems kind of crazy
that the Insiders be buying at the High
when they could have been buying at the
low so why would the Insiders pile into
the stock at the high end of the range
what what I've learned that this means
is when the iders buy at the high what
they're essentially saying is yes the
market recognizes that things are good
here but it still doesn't recognize just
how good things are I mean things are
even better than people think so so it
seems counterintuitive but if a stock is
hitting new highs and the Insiders are
buying at the same time those stocks
tend to really take off so um I'm
looking all sorts of additional factors
in addition to the fact that just some
insiders are buying some shares at the
company that they where they work so
this simple idea that I i l to buying
with insiders then you go into the
detail on it it's actually fairly labor
intensive so I'm getting a sense that
it's not just you with a green visor on
sitting at your desk figuring all this
out if you what does your support staff
look like well I have quite a few
dedicated researchers that are looking
at this information collating it for me
every week uh I'm looking at every
single company that has uh Insider
buying but I'm starting I I'm going to
see the big biggest Insider buys first
so I'm narrowing it down to the biggest
buys by the most knowledgeable people uh
in the companies that I think have the
best prospects going forward so it is
very labor intensive in that we're we're
going through the electronic filings at
the SEC we're digging into the companies
uh because it's great to see The Insider
buying but what what's the sales Outlook
what what are the what's the earnings
Outlook is a company earning a higher
return on Equity they got new products
coming out is there strong institutional
support what do the technical indicators
on the stock look like so we take all
the things into account uh and really
it's just a matter of of continually
winwing out stocks so that you start
with a a large number and you get a
smaller and smaller and then in the very
end you're you're left with just a
couple of candidates to choose from and
those are the ones I I make my
recommendations on and then you're not
compensated by these companies in any
way no no they don't they have no idea
who I even have but but that's this is a
great thing this is public information I
can tell you all the smart money the
hedge fund managers and uh other big
Wall Street Big Wigs they're they're
watching what the Insiders are doing
like a hawk they know exactly what this
means you know here's the surprising
thing though what'll often happen is a
CEO or chairman will buy millions of
dollars with his own company stock with
his own money it hits the wire and on
the news the stock spikes up but then
time goes by oh there's been a delay in
the trade deal with China oh the FED is
not going to cut rates anymore what and
the stock starts coming right back down
and I'm telling you within a couple of
weeks you can buy cheaper than the
chairman did so so if if you just
know what's going on and watch carefully
and pick your spots you'd be surprised
that you can actually buy these stocks
cheaper than the Insiders did it happens
all the time but going all the way back
to the beginning like this to me sounds
like fun but it's all based on the
mindset of taking some money out of your
spending and putting it into your wealth
yeah I often say if you don't work and
you don't save I can't help you and
that's why I think that we're in a a
tough moment because I think a lot of
millennials T tend to think that if they
vote for the right person who will
redistribute wealth in the right way
that they will somehow get the money
they need to that's not going to work
and it's never worked that's just not
the the American way if you want to
change economic inequality the only
economic inequality that matters which
is your own it's you have to take action
you have to work you have to save you
have to invest you you can't vote for
somebody who's going to redistribute it
to you that's just it's really just not
going to happen it's a pipe dream and I
have to say that when I was a young man
and I was Indigent I didn't have savings
I didn't have health insurance I didn't
have a retirement account I had nothing
it never even occurred to me that if the
if the government would just take it
from those people over there and give it
to me I mean that that never never
struck a chord with me I would have
thought that's pathetic quite frankly I
mean I I you really have to get into the
mindset that if things are going to
change for the better you're going to be
The Driver behind it you're going to
make it happen not somebody else and and
that's that's the mindset that leads to
wealth creation and so I would encourage
people if you want to get rich start not
just dreaming but making plans setting
goals and uh and follow through perfect
well I know that that you have
subscribers that pay for your your
thinking is there a place where people
can follow you without paying without
subscribing to anything just see what's
I have a free e-letter that I write I
write two columns a week for Liberty
through wealth so went to Liberty
through wealth.com
um you could see exactly uh my thoughts
on the economy and the markets and life
in general I've right about everything
under the sun and I I'll show you
exactly how our business model works we
offer a free e-letter which we obviously
lose great gobs of money on in the hopes
that people will subscribe to our
investment letter and uh then beyond the
investment letters we have short-term
trading Services one of which is based
solely on Insider buying for instance um
but that's how our our business model
essentially works I love it I love your
philosophy and love what you're doing
yeah thanks thank you very much for
being here thanks for having
[Music]
me hello again and welcome back I hope
you enjoyed episode one of wealth
breakthroughs three different approaches
entrepreneurship real estate and stock
market investing three different paths
to wealth breakthroughs that could
change your life forever
right now I'd like to encourage you to
share this episode with anyone in your
life you think could benefit from seeing
it look the need for wealth
breakthroughs is all around us millions
of Americans know they're capable of
more capable of living the life they
really want to live but they're held
back stuck in place by the 9-to-5 grind
wealth breakthroughs breaks that old way
of thinking forever and puts you on
track for a life of true wealth and
freedom kids colleagues neighbors family
and friends share this episode with
anyone you know searching for their own
wealth breakthrough I'll see you next
time for episode two thanks for
watching hi there and welcome to wealth
breakthroughs episode one bonus
interview Jeff Walker burn that name in
your mind because what he has to say in
this interview could change your life
forever starting the moment you watch
what he has to say Jeff went from a
financially struggling stay atome dad to
having a hand in helping generate over
$1 billion in Revenue plus he started
his business with just a few hundred
doar Jeff has breakthrough ideas about
how you can turn your talents and
passions into money-making businesses
he's an amazing thinker and one of the
world's most qualified people to discuss
real wealth breakthrough Cruise ladies
and gentlemen here's Jeff
[Music]
Walker Jeff I'm very much looking
forward to this interview you've had
such a massive impact on my life so I'm
now excited to share you with the rest
of the world thank you so much I'm
really excited to be here so you know
the theme Here of wealth breakthroughs
uh is something that I know you
personally can speak to and I think your
experience personally plus what you
found since your wealth breakthrough uh
can really have an impact on a lot of
people so can we hear your story tell us
about kind of your trajectory and how
you got to be doing what you're doing
today yeah it's been an amazing journey
when I think about wealth um just the
evolution in my life in my lifestyle and
the impact I've been able to make and
and my thinking about money and wealth
is just it's hard to even imagine so
back in the mid90s I was a stay-at-home
dad and I wasn't a stay-at-home dad
because I had a do com and I sold out
for $30 million and I was just sitting
back and playing with the kids I'd been
a corporate failure and uh I I was I was
in the corporate game and it just didn't
fit I was at square peg in the round
hole and so I left it I quit when my
when we had our my son was born when he
was a year just a year old I left and my
wife was supporting the family and uh it
was a struggle this was the
mid90s and back then it wasn't such a
thing there weren't very many dads
staying home and by the way we were on
one income and it was desperate times uh
we didn't have much money to go around
there was one time where I put together
a budget we had $400 in disposable
income for the year and so by disposable
income like after I went through the
budget and said this is our rent and
this is our
groceries $400 wow and so it was
desperate times and so I was looking
around for ways to make money and I
ended up starting to publish online I
started publishing a newsletter it
actually a newsletter about the stock
market and investing and I had a lot of
interest in investing at that time I
didn't have any money to invest so I
just studied and studied and studied and
so that first newsletter went out to I
like to tell this story of it went out
to 19a email addresses 19 people that I
knew their email address that I thought
might be interested in my newsletter and
it was really not 19 people because one
of those email addresses was my second
email address and one was my wife's
email address but I felt better about
saying I had 19 people subscribed to
this newsletter that eventually started
to grow through word of mouth and I
started to add a few subscribers per day
and then a few hundred per month and it
just grew and grew and grew I came out
with a paid version of that newsletter
because initially it was just free and I
started to build a business and that the
I did a launch I'm now famous for doing
launches and for teaching people how to
do online launches but that first launch
I did
$1,650 in sales and if you flash back to
what my disposable income was I was just
I was flabbergast I was amazed it was an
incredible amount of money it was
amazing I was doing backflips not
literally figuratively doing back flips
but I was literally jumping in the air
to have
$1,650 in income and I had this thought
right then that what might have been one
of the most important thoughts I ever
had in my life and it was like if I did
that once I can do it again and I can do
it again and again and I I probably I
might get better at this and that's what
happened so the next launch did
$6,000 huge Quantum for X almost over
$1,650 and then $8,000 and then
gradually figured that stuff out and I'm
going to tell this story in a very
concise way but it didn't it was one
step in front of the other right
eventually a few years later I did
$34,000 in a single week in a launch for
another newsletter a brand new
newsletter and that was the launch that
brought my wife Mary home and she was
able to to retire retire to come home be
with the kids help with the kids and
help me grow my business and it just
didn't stop there a few years later I
actually we were ready to buy a home and
I needed a down payment so I did a
launch that did
$106,000 in a single week and then
eventually I started to help friends and
then eventually I did launches I did
millions of dollars and here we are a
short 20 some years later and I've now
built up this business where I've got 30
employees I've got my influencers all
over the world we have my products being
licensed I've got a bestselling book it
just goes on and on and my students and
clients have done over a billion dollars
in
sales and uh it's just like I said been
a rocket ride so if you know as you're
telling the story and you're thinking
back to the time that you're a stay-at
home Dad and then you know you sit where
you are right now having this
conversation is it is it somewhat
unimaginable to you
it is it's absolutely back then the
thought that a anyone would ever want to
buy anything from me that I created was
the furthest thing from my mind I wasn't
a marketer I wasn't a salesperson I I
just got worked for a paycheck before
and not been terribly successful at that
so the idea that anyone would buy
something from me was crazy the idea
that someone would want to interview me
actually and have fancy cameras and a
and a set and like it's just like No And
if you would to asked anyone around me
that surrounded me they be like Jeff why
would why would people want to interview
Jeff but here's the interesting thing
it's not like you had some guide book or
reference point you literally started
with a need which was saying I need to
make some income and I have an interest
basically which I guess was the stock
market and what I find ironic is saying
I have no money to invest in the market
but I still want to study it maybe what
I'm studying I could share and it's
worth something to somebody but you
started to figure out these these launch
models to be able to work from home and
and get this done and you you innovated
this whole thing and you literally
created an industry you know cuz I've
I've in my own businesses have used your
work and it's translated into millions
and millions of dollars of Revenue and
and when I look at how you got started
it wasn't like you went to some slick
ivy league university had a degree you
studied and analyzed a market you saw a
market need you you know all those kinds
of business cases that you try to you
know that feel you're a guy that
literally had $400 a year of disposable
income and figured it out out is there
something special about you I mean how
did you get that figured out very
gradually and
incrementally uh I would like to say I
just had this genius plan from the start
but I'm a big fan of of baby steps and
and just moving in the direction and
course correcting an analogy I like to
use is golf you take so I've done some
golfing in my life I'm not a huge golfer
but I've done some golfing and the thing
I've noticed about golf is you take it's
a little white ball and there's this
little hole and it's a third of the a
mile away and it's completely improbable
that you can hit this little golf ball
into this hole a third of the mile it's
just ridiculous but you can take someone
who's never golfed before their first
hole ever and they'll swing and they
might miss the ball they'll probably
miss the ball they'll probably the first
time they hit it it'll go sideways maybe
even backwards but you give them 10 or
12 or 13 or 14 tries and they'll end up
every time putting that ball in the hole
and it's because they gradually course
correct they hit that first one it's way
over there and the second one's way over
there but as they get closer they course
correct I'm a big fan of baby steps of
just taking that first step that next
step and then gradually course
correcting until you hit the goal and so
for me I just it was desperation now so
many people are interested in impact and
I'm in this game now for impact that's
why I'm here with you that's why I
travel to be here with you for impact
because that's what my world's evolved
into but back then it was desperation
and needing money yeah but I would say
from the start I did have a few things
the this internet this connected world
was just starting to happen this was
1996 right when I first
started and I had some instincts I think
that served me well because I think the
world really did change with this
connected world and there's some certain
words that get tossed around like
integrity and
authenticity um in congruence that
really that's what business is largely
about now because everything is so
transparent people can look up your
reviews instantly they can check your
social they can see what you're what
you're really delivering to the world
and everything I've do everything I've
done every my entire model of business
is is built on honest congruent sharing
with people and building value before
you ask for the sale and that was
something I I think I got that from my
parents yeah really I think I just got
that from my parents and I carry that
into business and I didn't have anyone
to tell me that's not the right way to
do business because I was just figuring
it out on my own in 1996 1997 there was
almost no one doing business online and
so I didn't have anyone to learn from so
I just stumbled into this and gradually
evolved it and and here we are today you
know I think you there are many points
you made but one of them I think is
interesting is like you you don't come
across as the guy that's going to get
hired to be a you know a salesperson you
know in a in a corporate environment
that go out there and push a product
what have you but a fundamental
principle saying you know just build
some value before you even ask is is
literally the driver you know or one of
the big drivers behind you know what you
do and it's it's almost in that respect
it's almost not sales I mean technically
I guess it's sales but it's it's not
salesmanship so to speak right and that
principle applied to the very first
launch you did still applies now just as
much or no it absolutely more so now
more so because there's more
transparency now people can can find you
they can see you they can look at
reviews that stuff didn't exist right
you know my first probably eight years
online there was not even a photo of me
online because we didn't share photos
back then but if you would have at the
beginning and frankly I went through
this so before I started this I was like
my original thinking was we need more
money Mary needs some kind of relief of
this pressure of having to support the
family and getting up in the dark and
coming home in the dark and working so
hard and and so I need to make money in
some way so I thought maybe I'll go get
a job and so I went to all these career
counseling and I took these tests to see
what you were suited for and I don't
have them anymore but I guarantee if you
looked at them and you looked at this
whole
Spectrum like of what's the most likely
place I'd have success sales would be
like I'd be in the 0 percentile for
sales I have no sales experience I have
no um sales instincts right and really I
think what I ended up doing is because I
didn't know how to sell and I was
uncomfortable with selling I was
uncomfortable asking for money then I
ended up overcompensating by building
value building value building value
before I asked for the sale
and lo and behold it ended up like
working really really well and turning
out to be the way the the world is
tilted that way now so it's interesting
because it's almost like you you turned
a weakness into a strength right yes
absolutely so it worked for you not to
be able to have a very slick sales
ability yeah that's interesting so and
you sort of answered this question
already but I want to be clear in it you
know the principles and the idea of uh
you know doing a launch of a product is
some value that you can create for a
particular audience uh that ship hasn't
sailed it's not like oh you know if you
didn't get in on it at a good time it's
today there's people who are still
starting from scratch applying these
principles and making them work yeah I
started that first launch was at the
very end of 96 uh no one knew what I was
doing because I just had a few by that
time thousands of people on my on my
email list it grew and grew and grew in
2001 I went to my my first marketing
conference I thought everyone was doing
this stuff I shared it with a few people
I started coaching a few people through
it in like 20012 three and they had
success with it and up till then I I
just thought it was working for me I
didn't know if it worked for it work for
them in other markets like writing love
letters or how to get traffic to your
website and or for airline PL pilots and
it started to work in other markets so
in 2005 I started teaching it and people
started having success in just about
every Market with any type of product
you could
imagine and really the results now are
bigger than they've ever been just a few
months ago we had the biggest launch
ever that I know of in our kind of
little bootstrapped kind of businesses
that that was literally in the many tens
of millions of dollars wow
and
yeah yeah yeah exactly and and and this
isn't uh you know something that is uh
you know it's fading it seems like it's
actually gaining momentum even more so
now uh why do you think that is well I
think there's more people online mhm I
think than there's ever been and there's
more people coming online I think
there's more people that are buying
online there's more people walking
around with their phones I mean it
wasn't that long ago we didn't have the
phone you had to be on your computer be
online now we're on everyone's on online
all day long every day I also think many
of my clients are selling what I call
wisdom products or training products
knowledge products you could call them
and so the whole idea of of consuming
training
online electronically has exploded uh
the the interest in people in furthering
themselves frankly I think I see a lot
more interest in self-education I think
it's become the norm I think the dollars
being spent on self-education are going
through the roof and so the Market's
growing the acceptance of buying that
online is growing and people are are
creating bigger followings faster and
then they're able to sell a lot better
and more effectively yeah and here's I
think one of this call a special aspect
of what you're doing it's kind of the uh
the warmth and humanitarian side is that
you know we can talk about certainly
there's some people who are running
somewhat scale Enterprises that can do
you know tens of millions of dollars on
a launch but there's also musicians or
people that have you know like teachers
that you know they don't have much
income they have no big staff or
anything around them and they would look
at uh series like this you wealth
breakthroughs you know how and they
would say I'm not in that position to
create a wealth breakthrough for me and
and I think it's contextual in many
respects you know you have that person
who said you know here's what my passion
in life was I eek out a living I don't
have a lot of disposable income I know
nothing really about investing and nor
do I maybe even have a lot of Desire
there but I would like to enhance my
financial position with you know like
for you a $1600 launch was a wealth
breakthrough right I mean that was the
biggest launch of my life I I've I had a
launch that did a million dollars in
sales in 53 minutes and the impact of
that million dollars that Pals and
comparison to the
$1,650 yeah and so really poignant is
fact saying the wealth breakthrough
doesn't have to be this huge thing for
whoever it is that that that's watching
or that has some type of a passion it
could be something much smaller but
extraordinarily meaningful so when you
have people and I know you've had many
that approach you and say I got limited
means I've got some maybe relationships
I do have a skill I'd like to figure out
how to translate this into a a product
that other people would care about um
what are the steps how do you guide them
that's a big question so there there's
many different flavors not many
different ways you can go and I think
that if someone's got a skill and it's a
skill that they can transfer to someone
else that they can train with someone
that they can coach someone and
especially if you've worked with a few
people even informally you've helped a
couple friends through a partnership
breakup or helped them learn how to
meditate or showed someone a few guitar
chords and you've had some success
working one-on-one then the next this is
a tried andrue path is you go from there
to small group coaching and online
electronically is a great way to do that
and so it these days it's so much
simpler because you could literally do a
live broadcast on Facebook or on
Instagram or who knows by the time
people watch this there's probably going
to be a new channel right and those
tools are available for free and so you
could put together a small launch put a
small group of people and by small it
could be six people a dozen people it
could be I would love it to be 30 people
30 or 40 people would be like the ideal
number but that small group onto a call
onto a live broadcast and teach and the
beautiful thing about this is what it's
very interactive so part of the process
is that you survey people and first of
all the part the first STP is you you
take your topic whatever it is if it's
guitar you split it into five main
content areas and say we're going to do
five of these broadcasts and that's what
you're actually selling right then you
get on the broadcast or before the
broadcast you do a simple survey and
there's plenty of free survey tools out
there you can Google's got one Survey
Monkey got one you ask you say to people
hey this is going to be our first topic
for our first call what do I need to
cover what's your most burning question
about that topic you gather all those
questions and that's why I want you to
have it'd be ideal if you had 30 people
go through this with you so that you
have a critical mass and you get the
good questions and then you just get on
you simply answer those questions and
then you do that five times for each one
of those topics and you've got yourself
your first product and what you've done
is you've developed a training that's
tuned to what people want because if you
are that expert meditator or if you're
the expert guitar player you've
forgotten what it's like to be a
beginner right we call this the curse of
knowledge you've forgotten that but in
doing this process you're tapping in
back into those beginners figuring out
what they need to learn and now you're
teaching that to them and that's how you
create a great product the first time
out and then from that is what you
continue to relaunch and monetize over
time and try to keep building your
audience yeah I I literally so my Pro my
training on how to do these launches
it's called Product launch formula right
and I did this process I had six people
six people go through it and because I I
wanted to have more then I invited a
bunch of friends I I I let them in on a
complimentary basis so we got up to that
30 I did the training over those five
calls I added in three or four bonus
calls because I obsessed about overd
delivery that initial set of calls then
I remade I reshot those because again I
obsess about I I got that Perfection
streak which is not a good thing for
entrepreneurs but I've got that streak
so I rebuilt it and that product which
has now been rebuilt I don't know how
many many times but it started with that
one launch that what we call a seed
launch for the six people so that is now
from six people we've had tens of
thousands of people go through it I've
done tens of millions of dollars in
sales I put people into my events a
thousand people come to my events from
around the world they've done over a
billion dollars in launches all from
starting off with a training for six
people you still get giddy as you talk
about this so it's just ridiculous it's
ridiculous what the what the whole
online world has done for bootstrapped
entrepreneurs and by bootstrapped if
people don't know what I mean it's
people that you can start with nothing
you're not going out and you're trying
not trying to land Venture Capital
you're not trying to get investors
you're just starting with what you've
got with a few dollars I started this
business I went and I rented a mailbox
at mailboxes Etc and that was my it was
like less than $50 and that was all the
money I spent for the first six months
in business and here we are
and this is available to anyone so with
this experience and listening to the
story and the history behind it you know
sometimes I talk to people and they're
like you know I set goals and I had a
vision and I wanted to you know create
this big wealth and I when I was eight
or nine years old you know I I knew that
I wanted to be wealthy I didn't want a
job and in your case you know it it
seems almost a little bit the headp
space was a bit different that this is
still almost to some degree shocking to
you that it turned out this way so talk
to me about your Reflections on the the
headp space for wealth generation and
creating Financial Independence well
when I first started out I did find one
training product and it was called turn
your computer into a money machine and
that sounds hopelessly cheesy now
hopelessly cheesy and it came on a
floppy disc and and I spent
$99.50 and I had to think about spending
that money for a week I lay in bed each
night thinking about writing a check
because that's what I eventually wrote
the check I mailed the check they mailed
me a floppy disc Sheila Danzig is the
person who created this and that Flappy
do changed my life it was some of the
basics of of really direct marketing and
this it wasn't even about the internet
it was about like America online and
comp Ser if anyone remembers those
progenitors of the internet and and it
had this one little one page that said
oh there's this thing coming called the
internet it might be cool so that
training part of that training she had
you set goals so I sat down and and
there's many ways to set goals there's
the smart goals and the achievable goals
and the the shoot for the moon goals and
her she said think really big as big as
you can possibly think so it was sort of
the shoot for the moon goals and I did
that I took a very Ser was it hard for
you to do that no no so I wrote down an
in income goal it was
$100,000 and uh and then I wrote down a
lot of Lifestyle goals and I I wrot I
wanted to have a fast computer I wanted
to have a nice office I wanted to I love
spending time out in the wilderness on
River trips I wanted to wanted to go
paddling in Ecuador I wanted to do a
Grand Canyon river trip I wanted to have
all these days you you remember these
goals all these years later because i' I
still have them I still have the print
out because I typed them up and I
printed it out wow I wanted these days
so many days with my family I wanted to
weigh a certain weight I wanted to and
yeah I listed them all out and uh pretty
much the funny thing is those goals are
the same goals I've got now the number
the the dollar I actually don't even
have a goal for for income anymore I
just I've left that behind and if I did
write one it be bigger than $100,000 now
but um yeah the so I did set those goals
I did have this vision and it's a crazy
because I I it wasn't like I look at it
all the time but like 10 years later I
found them a print out it's like wow and
I hit all of them but they were all
relevant to me because right from the
beginning I defined that lifestyle and
health and relationships was part of my
goals it wasn't about just about money
well this is really fascinating for me
because a lot of times people have the
perspective how their life would change
or how they'd be different if they had
more money right and uh you know and a
lot of times people will look at other
people who have made a lot of money and
say oh money Chang them but in essence
you're saying that you know what what I
wanted out of life is no different
before I had money than now when I have
it I would agree with that 100% I think
I don't think money necessarily changes
I think money amplifies yeah who you
are yeah and if you're a good person
you're happy with yourself I think it'll
amplify those things if there's some
challenges I think I can amplify those
things as well yeah that's actually a
really uh astute observation just
amplifies so maybe if there's some
things that people want a wealth
breakthrough maybe they have to take a
look in the mirror first and say uh
maybe there's some things I want to fix
about myself before I get on that train
yes I might phrase it a little
differently in that
that you're not going to be able to make
big changes in your relationship to
money in the the the money you have and
the impact in any area like if you w to
start a
business you're going to become a
different person yeah if you want to
have great wealth you're going to become
a different person you're going to have
to become a different person and it
doesn't need to be scary uh I don't want
to scare people off I think it's a great
big Journey you know a number of years
ago for the longest time we had a very
very small team multi-million dollar
business with really myself and my wife
Mary and like two other people and and
then a few years ago I just decided I
our work is just too important and I and
we were helping too many people and I
I'd actually gotten some bad advice
early on in my career about don't build
a team it's just going to make your life
a living hell which I think was was
horrible advice to me at the time and so
so I got worked my way through that I
said if I'm really going to build my
impact I got it's time to start building
a team and then I went and got some
coaching on that and the coaching was
yeah you're gonna there you can build a
team but to build a team you want that's
really going to
perform and be able to serve and you're
you're going to have to learn to serve
them and you're going to have there's
going to be some personal development
there's going to be a journey for you
and I was like bring it on because this
is going to be the most interesting
learning I'm going to have you know in a
long time is is learning how to be a
leader and really learning how to be a
servant leader and so every if you want
to start a business if you want that
wealth you know what if you wantan to
any major change in your life you're GNA
have to you have to show up and do the
work so you kind of anticipated a
question I don't know if what you just
said is the answer if there other things
but I would like to know some of the big
lessons or some of the highlights that
you've learned along the way that you
share with people now well yeah yeah so
I've mentioned a few of them um first of
all any anytime that you're going to to
make a big shift a successful shift it
it starts in here it starts here and it
starts here uh it's it's all a personal
development process it's all a process
and frankly if someone's watching this
they've already started the process
right they have already started the
process and then one of the things I've
noticed is that anyone I get to hang out
with a lot of successful people just so
many dozens and probably hundreds of
self-made
millionaires people that are doing great
work having great impact making a great
income and what I've noticed is they're
all into personal development yeah every
single one of them I thought I was like
the weirdo because like in the mid 90s
in addition I I bought two programs back
then it was the first one was to turn
your computer into money machine and the
other one was I bought Tony Robbins
personal power to two off the
infomercial and I was when I bought that
I it was I was sort of embarrassed I I I
I hid it I went through it all and it it
made an incredible impact on my life
unbelievable impact but I was
embarrassed I thought like I must be
broken that I need to do this personal
development because it really wasn't a
thing that was out
there then you get around a bunch of
successful people and you realize that
we've all got this addiction to personal
development to to Growing our game to
Growing our mental game so that was that
was a really a huge one and and that
continues to this
day I think for me things like I
remember when I was trying to be a stock
market Trader I bought a program then
this is a after I had enough success
where I could spend some more money on
programs and the program talked about
you know nutrition and meditation and
I'm like I just want to trade the stock
market what why is he talking about
nutrition and meditation like who cares
car about that tell me like one to buy
and one to sell right well lo and behold
now you know took me a decade to learn
that taking care of your body my friend
Joel poish likes to say you need to
treat yourself like a million-dollar
race horse because you know news flash
you are the million-dollar race horse so
taking care of yourself how you eat how
you sleep um your your spiritual health
your mental health you know I meditate
every day yoga every day I stretch every
day I generally get some type of
activity every day I'm aiming for eight
hours of sleep every
night those type of things make a huge
impact so in the if we call this a game
of creating wealth or success how much
of it is headspace versus how much of it
is you know the other stuff well as the
person who sells the other stuff the
training the other uh I'd say it's it's
80% the mental game the inner game you
know for me here's another one it's been
a a Non-Stop journey of learning to
think bigger learning to think bigger
are you still and you're still learning
to think bigger now absolutely it
doesn't stop how do you learn that well
for a long time it was I would just look
at other people that were a few steps
further ahead than me and so it was it
was pretty easy for a while I remember
you know I had that $100,000 goal right
and then I hit the within a few years
and then it was really easy to think
about a double to get to $200,000 and so
right when I was about $200,000 I went
to a seminar and I I remember this to
the day I was I was at this marketing
seminar it's one of the first seminars I
ever went to and I we're in the buffet
line you know and we're just spooning
you know the green beans out of the
buffet line and get to talking to the
guy next to me and we just started
talking about our businesses and he just
casually mentioned that he was doing
$100,000 a month so his business is over
a million dollars he was the first
person i' ever met had a business over a
million dollars and I'm like you know
he's spooning those green beans onto his
plate just like I'm spooning the green
beans onto my plate the thought of a
million-dollar business hadn't even
occurred to me and really to go I'd
already done the hard work I got to
200,000 I mean to go from 200,000 to a
million it's a lot easier than from zero
to even 10,000 right and it's like okay
well I guess it's it's doable and then a
couple years later I went to another
seminar and I heard this there was
someone there who had a product and it
was about dating it was teaching guys
how to get dates and they said their
business is doing five million and just
to show you how how this thinking can
just keep on creeping in I'm like
there's no possible way they could be
doing $5 million it's just ridiculous
that a business like ours could be doing
and dating advice give me a break I just
I don't believe it even though by that
point my business was at a million
dollars I mean to go from a million to
five million again that's a lot easier
than than that those first few steps but
but it had creeped back into my thinking
this limited thinking but then I dug
behind the scenes and yeah they were
doing five million and a couple years
later 25 million and so again I don't
we're talking a lot about money just
because it's an easy measure to to make
it's an easy one to talk about it's an
easy
scorecard but that I just kept on
looking for people that were a little
further Beyond and then at some point I
started to um run out of because my
business is at at the higher end of most
online businesses and especially when
you account for the fact that I also
have a pretty amazing lifestyle and I
get a lot of time off right um so it can
be but these days it's it's most most ly
driven by the impact yeah like we'll do
things at my events we'll bring people
on stage that have had great success and
now I'm measuring myself more by how
many people I can have on stage with me
that have had that amazing success or
how much money we can we've raised a lot
of money for different nonprofits I'm
very proud that I had that initially had
that $100,000 goal and now we regularly
raise 100,000 or
$200,000 for for nonprofits at my events
if I we did a million dooll fundraiser
at one of my events so so it's driven
more these days by that impact and and
that's where my thinking is getting
bigger I think I guess yeah when you
when you get out of survival and uh and
now you got momentum uh you know then
you can start thinking more about impact
and you know money becomes a means of
expanding the impact as compared to
expanding your your bank account I guess
at that point since I've been teaching
for so long now and I've gotten to know
my people so well they there's this sort
of um the spectrum of I want to make a
million dollars or I just want to save
the world and people usually come into
my world with one of those right and I
love the impact people because that's
where I'm at but I totally identify with
I just want to make the money because I
can remember when I was desperate and
the funny thing is is the folks that
just want to save the world they end up
finding out that it takes money to save
the world you know you just you just
can't continually put your work out
there and just give and give and give
and give without getting and without
funding right and then those people that
want to make the million bucks they they
start almost without fail almost without
fail because I've seen so many people go
through this they start to get that that
uh that wealth they start to get that
abundance in their lives and then they
start to think about wow is that all
there is what can I do how can I help
it's sort of like the old adage the best
way to help the poor is not be one of
them exactly yeah exactly so you know as
you're looking at reference points to
say okay how do how I can set your
markers as far as you know what's my
next level of growth how do I think
bigger you know it seems to come through
inspiration so how do you see the role
of inspiration in all this so I think
that at the end of the day what we're
doing at least in my world and this
really for any
entrepreneurs is we're creating from The
Ether yeah we have a thought and then we
turn that thought into reality and in
that one sentence I just said there's a
lot of work and there's a lot of sweat
and it's hard and there's there's times
where you doubt yourself and there's
times where you just have to muscle
through but at the end of the day we
think of something we see it in our
Mind's Eye and then we create
it and at that very first moment there's
inspiration there and there's
inspiration all the way through and you
need to stay inspired and and you know
what no one stays inspired all the time
and that's where you get back to like
the mental game the inner game taking
care of yourself for me it is about the
meditation it's about exercise it's
about being out in the woods it's about
going for runs out in the forest it's
about getting away in Wilderness trips
those are the things that fire me up
those things and then just getting face
to face with other creators and face to
face with with my people at my events
I'm I'm I'm a natural inine
like I'm like at the at the cocktail
party I'm the one in the corner and I'm
just going to find try to find one
person I can talk to and then just try
to be as entertaining for that one
person just so they don't leave me you
know and so I'm just gonna be talking
talking talking because I'm just not a
natural moving through the room but when
I get to my events then I turn into an
extrovert I get on stage because I'm
around these people yeah my people that
are out there changing the world they're
making a huge impact that are building
their lives that are designing their
lives that are are taking the rein of
their lives and creating the life they
want and that's where I get inspiration
when you look back over you know your
trajectory and and you the experiences
you've had any mistakes that you
highlight saying boy these were these
were mistakes I made that uh other
people can learn from I think for me an
easy one is that it took me to too long
to start building a team mhm we were way
under staff for way too long so that was
the number one there was a time where I
think some people might see this as a
mistake but like in this world there are
times when the sun just shines on you
you know it's the Beatles White Album
you know it's just it's just that when
everything comes together and there was
a time for me in 20072 2008 where
everyone in the world was just talking
about me and thought it was the it was
the the moment it was the wave was
crusting or the first huge wave was
crusting and at that time my son was in
his mid to late teens my daughter was in
her early teens and I just said I'm not
going to travel now this is that would
have been a time for me to be out there
on stage speaking every month and I said
I'm just going to pull back I'm not
going to travel I'm sure I could have
made money a lot more money I could have
built the the business faster but that
was a decision that I'm super happy with
that definitely worked for me so some
people on a financial basis some people
might want to look at that and say that
was a mistake but for me that that
worked it goes back to those original
goals you wrote and saying you know this
is who I am and uh you you didn't take a
opportunity over values mhm you the
value was being with my kids more than
the opportunity to make more yep really
interesting what do you think the future
is going to be now so you know so here
we are you what you do is still on fire
you you obviously are still completely
like animated about it uh you know
you're excited about you know the
prospects for people doing online
businesses to create Financial Freedom
to have wealth breakthroughs um is what
do you think is on the horizon what what
what's coming I've been asked that
question for a long time because in this
business a lot of folks are just always
moving on to the next thing right and
I've sort of stayed in my Lane yeah and
my product product lunch formula has
become a brand it's become an actual
brand in a in a world where there were
not Brands so this is arguably the first
brand that existed in this online
information U training certainly in the
entrepreneurial training World there
it's the first one to become a brand
it's now you know 14 15 years old old
now and all along I've just kept on
iterating it and making it better
because I I am fired up about it I'm
excited about it in the last few years
it used to be that I couldn't in my mind
couldn't talk about impact it was back
in 2005 people just they didn't want to
hear about impact they wanted to hear
about money
so thankfully that has shifted and and
it's okay to talk about impact and
that's been
a joy to me to share that piece I think
um one of the things that I've it's it's
a Non-Stop Journey for me a Non-Stop
development I just spent uh eight days
out doing a vision quest to figure out
what what my path was including a a 4day
water fast and three day solo out in the
woods all by myself fasting out in
Montana in the wi it was a winter snow
on the ground it was a crazy time to get
a vision and uh and my vision is that
this path I'm on is is a pretty amazing
one so I want to keep on evolving that
and one of the things I see that a lot
of entrepreneurs go and they create
something really cool and this is for
the more advanced people they create a
great business or what looks like a
great business on the outside but behind
the scenes it's it's a little um little
bit of a little bit of chaos there and a
little bit of internal chaos M and I
think that in fact I know that a lot of
entrepreneurs are they have some
Brokenness inside them sort of like if
you study behind the scenes every rock
star out there I've read every not every
I've read a lot of autobiographies of
rock stars probably a dozen or more and
almost every one of them came out of a
broken home yeah and that's what drove
them forward and I think many
entrepreneurs came out of
fundamentally d damaging circumstances
early in their
life and they go and they create
something cool and they create something
great and they still have that damaged
three and four year old inside them W so
it didn't heal them exactly so I think
there's a lot of people that have had a
lot of a lot of outside success and
their Instagram feed looks
amazing but I think if they healed some
of that stuff inside of them then they
could create even bigger and better and
more beautiful things
and for some reason I seem to be the
person who built the business and kept
the the marriage for 30 years and have
the kids who still like to hang out with
them and stayed in shape and I don't
know how I've been gifted to have this
life I've
got but I've done a lot of work to get
here and I think I've got a lot to share
on that to help some of those those
folks that have seemingly built the
business and the wealth they want but
still are feeling a little bit broken
inside so given that how do you define
wealth call it true wealth I think
having a daily joy and peace and
financial abundance my friend Dean
Jackson likes to have these phrases I
know I'm being successful when and then
you put our you you answer any way you
want and so like a couple of mine are I
know I'm being successful when I know
the phase of the moon
in other words I'm outside experiencing
a night sky often enough so I know what
phase the Moon is in it's I I probably
lost most of our viewers at that one but
I no I don't I think just the opposite I
think they said aha yeah right I know
I'm being successful
when I never have an alarm clock the
only time I use an alarm clock is on ski
days and when I've got a flight to
catch so I think it wealth is individual
I I do think there's a financial piece
I'm had a situation where I could never
work another day in my life and and my I
haven't grown my lifestyle in a huge way
it stayed pretty simple yes it's gotten
I do fly first class yes but I still in
the same home I was in 19 years ago that
I did that launch to buy oh you're still
in the same house yeah wow we in 99 so
when things were starting to happen we
got a new home but since 99 2000 yeah
lot of years yep something like that so
yeah same home I've I drive a Chevy
pickup you know because I'm going up the
mountain go skiing I'm going out to go
mountain biking uh you know n i Porsche
911 like what I you know it not going to
fit my mountain bike in the back of that
so for me a key is having enough
financial abund abundance so that I
don't have to work that I can that I can
choose to work that being able to get
outside having a relationship with my
kids where they still want to be with me
and still we still mountain bike
together we still ski together you know
having a strong marriage being healthy
eating the food I want being able to go
to a restaurant and not look at the
prices being able to eat organic food
all the
time being able to take off time yeah
isn't that a big part of it because I
guess being unhealthy and stressed but
you know having a lot of money in the
account is not the ticket right right
you know there's that saying the the man
or the woman with uh with good health
has a thousand problems one with poor
health only has one problem so if you
run yourself into the ground and you're
eating horribly and and you're living
unhealthily but you have a great big
bank account it's all going to come
crashing down so I have to ask cuz I'm
fascinated by this uh you know I'm going
to circle back to it what motivated you
to go uh on a 4-day fast go going into
you know Montana you know for another
three days of fast in the woods in the
middle of winter look what what drives
that there's a very long answer to that
but it's it is the reinvention and the
inspiration piece so I'm going to pop
back because there was a that launch
that did a million dollars in 53 minutes
that actually went on to do $3.7 million
in about 34 hours before we closed it
down we were overwhelmed we couldn't
take any more clients so even though
sales were coming in at $100,000 in an
hour we shut it down we said we enough
we can't we need to service our clients
right and so 3.7 million in 34 hours
that was in 2008 and that wasn't that
long from I just want to make
$100,000 and and they have a nice
computer
and I actually this this is going to
sound strange but it put me into a tail
spin I didn't know what my life was
about because I still had those goals
and I'd hit every single one of them in
fact 3.7 million is a lot more than a
100 it's 37 times and you know and I say
3.7 you don't get to keep all that there
are costs but still you keep a lot of it
and it's like what is my life about was
this all there is and what am I going to
do now and it sent me down this long
path of meditation Retreats and going to
Tony Robbins events and on and on and on
and eventually I figured it out it was
about making a big impact and then
periodically I get you have something
big happen and and so this past summer
we business is better than it's ever
been it's booming team's doing great
I've got lots of time off and I'm
sitting on the front porch meditating
and say what is next because we all need
something and that's next we all need it
and that's when this sort of this
opportunity to go on this Vision Quest
showed up and and it was the timing was
just perfect it was just a couple days
after our
launch and there's a big Confluence of
events but it it was just like the world
dropped this in my lap and and I'm G to
challenge myself I'm G to challenge
that's really what I was about is
challenging myself yeah that's
extraordinary you use this term launch
what do you mean by launch that's a
great question because I'm sure we've
already used the word a bunch and we're
probably going to use it a bunch more so
the idea of a launch is that you have a
product a
service uh it could be a widget it could
be a book it could be a piece of art
that you want to get out into the world
you want to sell right and so in the
context I use it it's this process that
I've
developed where you will build up to it
similar to the way that Hollywood would
build up to the release of a new film or
the gaming industry they're doing a
fantastic job these days of building up
to a release of their new game right and
it's the idea of you build value build
value build value so people know this is
coming before you actually ask for the
sale and so it's got a It's Kind like an
event yeah it's turning your markeet
into an event because these days there's
so there there there's so much noise out
there there is everyone's a publisher
and that's a beautiful thing but
everyone's a publisher and everyone's
got their Instagram feed and their
Facebook feed and that's overly full and
they're inbox and it's it's just
incredibly full and to stand out you do
want to take your marketing take your
message and turn it into an event and
that moment when a new product comes out
is a it's like it's like births it's
like weddings it's like graduations
those events grab our attention you want
to grab people's attention with that and
it could be for a new product or it
could be for a product that's on the
market that you want to re-release and
then it's just basically creating a new
offer around that re-release and
bringing it out there this Spirit of
contribution that you seem to be in now
you know uh you know what can you
contribute what can you do in that realm
do you think that this is something
that's always been a part of your uh
your thinking but now that you have the
means and the the time and the space to
do it you're doing it or did it emerge
from somewhere else I think I was wired
that way I think that there's this uh
strength finders is there this this book
where you go and you figure out your
strengths are and so yeah exactly and so
my number one strength is significance
and when I first read that I'm like what
does that even mean and then I read it
and well it sounds like I just have a
big ego really it's just an ego that
needs to be stroked that I want to feel
important but I think that's in the less
altruistic way maybe it's not just about
contribution maybe it's just about you
know about me feeling significant right
and I'm willing to go there because I
think it does end up building in a lot
of value for people but yeah that I
think that was something I was born with
yeah really interesting to see how that
unfolds so uh now if you were to uh look
back across you know you're now Decades
of experience and certainly a lot of
people are uh learning from you they're
modeling you they're inspired by you Etc
uh what's the thing that you think
you're most proud of the thing I'm most
proud of is the communities I've
built which a lot of people don't
necessarily see they see me out in the
world they see my marketing they see my
product they see my book but when they
actually come out and they truly
experience like a live
event I somehow have this capability to
create an intimate experience with a
thousand people in the room and I create
a community create a a bubble that wraps
around that room a bubble of incredible
possibility and connection and sharing
and so I'm really proud of that of of
those events those events they're a lot
of work they're risky they're expensive
to put on and I'll get through one of
them and I'll just be pretty much wiped
out and I'll be like never again and
then a week later it's like I I have to
do that because like look at what I
created and then from within there we
have um some smaller communities we have
like a a a group of of our highest end
clients that I I meet with and those
communities there the the level of
connection
sharing
contribution um support for each other
is just amazing so the world sees me as
this guy who figured out this laun stuff
and has been teaching it and I'm very
proud of that and I'm very I'm
incredibly proud of the results my
clients have gotten and the results
they're getting in some incredibly
worthy worthy Realms like helping
parents with autistic children or
helping parents be better parents or or
helping people with their mindfulness or
just on and on and on or even helping
people with their tennis game I'm proud
of that impact and those ripples because
I'm helping these people become known
experts that are reaching other people
so I'm really really super proud of that
I'm proud of that work I'm proud of what
we've contributed millions of dollars to
nonprofits but the the magic thing that
I love is those communities because when
you just see people light up and start
to connect within those events it's just
sheer magic that's awesome well I want
to just first say personally thank you
for the impact you've had on my life and
the people I serve and then secondly
thanks for just sharing this for all the
people who are viewing so thanks so much
for your time and effort you're welcome
it's been great danger to see the next
episode in the wealth breakthrough
series check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there when
people say money can't bu happen it's
like BS like we have access to so much
knowledge I think one of the biggest
secrets to wealth and ongoing wealth and
sustainable wealth is you must continue
to learn